to
hello everybody
[Music]
welcome to Wednesday April 26th
and we're off the rails baby we updated
the background thank you to Cameron we
now have the train
the train wreck is off to the side you
may notice uh some uh Goofs and gaps
flying around some UFOs and stuff so we
got the rabbit back the mythical uh
we have a mythical Jackalope here
so it's all come
back together yes thank you everybody
uh-oh
[Music]
oh no
fight
[Music]
Sonic I heard him laugh
you better not show that plane hitting
[Music]
this is good
I was afraid y'all were about to have
that plane CR hit those buildings bro
[__] you got me but there it is okay
we're back off the rails nice nice this
is us this is us right now
uh yeah today's episode we have no
sponsors so please consider yes becoming
a member
[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
viewers like you
right and we are supported by viewers
like you thank you for your support
actually members get uh alive every
Tuesday BTS crew reaction to lore videos
access to Discord participating chat and
polls Early Access to Live show tickets
that's it baby
[Applause]
[Music]
also you can consider going over to
teddyfresh.com and picking up some uh
some fashionable streetwear it's all
happening over there yes and by the way
we just did a photo shoot yesterday that
was so epic I can't wait for you guys to
see that we had we hired like a pyro
tech neck is that what it's called Pyro
uh yeah by a pyro a pyro guy a pyro guy
I heard a pyro guy yeah we hired a
professional pyro guy and we got all
this fire and [__] that's awesome but
yeah go you could consider support us
that way thank you thank you all right
to the show
now
I have some terrible news to share with
you guys at the top of the show today we
were supposed to have a beloved doctor
come and digitally uh insert inside all
most of the guys here in the office
digitally well that's actually finger
yeah that's what finger meant is digital
like your digits oh yeah
smart
big brain big brain Ethan moment thank
you digitally penetrate us uh and uh
unfortunately last
uh night he got cold fingers
and he said you know what I don't think
this is for me
I went immediately to a ZocDoc and left
50 fake reviews no I'm just kidding I
didn't do that he's a good guy I get it
so we're looking for alternative doctors
and we will find one
we will to come in here we have a pretty
decent lead but it was just such short
notice that yeah yeah and I'm gonna be
like no doctor I want you to use two
fingers
I was so pissed I was telling you before
the show I got all prepped and uh
clean extra clean and um did you um did
you do shout your butt I didn't do shot
my butthole but I gotta I gotta have a
clean ass yeah but I was just you know
well we'll we'll have a heads up next
time and uh but unfortunately it's not
happening today but the good news is we
put together a great show for you guys
which is you know unusual for us
finally
we have the Crowders uh wife left him
Mega episode which is just the F and I
mean listen you never want to make fun
of someone's divorce it's horrible but
with Crowder you want to make fun of any
Misfortune yeah
uh besides the fact that
Crowder is the family's value
conservative who talks about uh that
single families are ruining America of
course being racist talks about gay
people shouldn't be able to adopt and
yet here's this man with a broken
[__] family and his wife left his ass
because he's just so intolerable my wife
went out for pizza without me I mean how
many times has she caught him
cross-dressing and again I think that's
fine if you guys communicate about it
but walking in on that is going to be
shocking
you know
like how many times does she have to
walk in on him wearing her panties it's
just there's nothing wrong with it it's
just a shocking story we don't actually
know that that's we don't know why
they're getting divorced
right making a bit of an assumption here
well he does dress up he does
cross-dressing he does very much enjoy
dressing in women's clothing which is
not a problem it's a problem to him
that's the Irish that's the real irony
yeah not a problem for me but I got to
talk about my wife in this context
you're good liver King you're good I
wanted to wait until tomorrow to talk
about it because it kind of leans more
on the leftover side but my God it says
just it's like the hottest story right
now it's all over the Internet well and
because we are prostate uh
yeah yeah you know yeah like I agree I
mean I'm sure Hassan's having a field
day with it so yeah yeah I want to have
my fun with it too
yeah but what a loser huh and what's it
and what's the deal right what's the
deal with these white Christian Family
Values people can't stay married these
[__] cannot stay married to
save their life a lot of them seem mean
I think
right A lot of them don't respect women
could be the problem it could definitely
have something to do with that
uh and his take his video about this is
legendary
um so I'm looking forward to getting
through all that but first
ah
listen
[Music]
I I so don't want to do this but I feel
that it's getting to the point where I
have to
and I've tried I've tried my best to
avoid having to talk about this and I'm
not kidding
there was a post on the subreddit I just
said erase it because
if I have to talk about this Dad is
gonna look like a [__] idiot talk
about the allegations dad has been
popping off about
me and a b
just like for no damn reason and I don't
understand
what is wrong with this guy
yeah that guy yeah maybe maybe what
could be wrong with that guy and like I
don't I
I don't want to go in on him too hard uh
and I don't want to I don't want anyone
to give him a hard time but you know how
it is with when it comes to things about
me is that there's so many people that
hate me on the internet
when something like this happens and Dad
starts saying all this [__] about how we
made him cry and
um
he just cried a lot
and uh no he said I don't know he's
saying that I was we're super mean and
that we sabotaged him and that I'm a bad
person and stuff
that uh people take it and run with it
and build all this whole crazy narrative
so my policy on all these things
since
um
since years ago when you know the whole
internet turned on me when keemstar made
this whole propaganda campaign is to
always address this stuff
when it comes up before it turns into a
thing
yeah and I just want to say I was I was
very disappointed when I saw this it
hurt because uh I always you know I
considered that to be a close friend I
still do so this was very surprising to
see I literally just put out a video
prior to seeing these clips saying
nothing but good things about Dad
yeah I mean me too we we yeah I know we
got a little caught up in the moment I
admit that but when we came back we gave
him all the love I made a tweet about
him I invited him on the show he said no
which again
he he really
okay where do I start with this uh yeah
there's been a few posts on the
subreddit of people being like yo what's
the deal with Dad
um
let me start with
let's start with this one about a b
which I thought was so out of pocket
and I'm the reason we're only talking
about this at all is because of the the
[__] he said about me that's pretty wild
but uh here's it here's dad talking
about a b
after the fight or this is from the same
stream here it is let's take a look
Partners purposely don't go super hard
because they're protecting you so you're
training you don't want to get knocked
out before your fight so ABS punches
were the hardest I experienced but I
after he punched me I was like oh this
is nothing I can take these all night
that's why I took them and just worked
on his body but I think he would have
punched harder if his form was better
because he was throwing straight up
windmills
if the that's so [__] that's like so
corny bro
to be [__] talking AV like first of all
you won yeah that's it you he you won
bro you got the dub you're gonna come
out and like [__] on your opponent who
by the way trained super hard and by the
way dude as tough as you want to act
your ass was scared as [__] I saw you
yeah we all saw you getting your ass
beat out there in that first round and
Peter people who are saying this is a
bit I messaged him myself yesterday
responded to me saying same thing and
saying that he's just it came from a
place of him being upset that he trained
so hard and I didn't and I don't like I
can't I couldn't believe what I was
hearing like that maybe trained like so
I went through hell and I was okay with
the loss you know but hearing [__] like
this when I initially heard it
Lena was live on stream and that's when
someone sent it to me and I was like all
right let's go to it let's go to a gym
this week and let's let's Spar dead if
you want to have a camera it's up to you
I don't give a [__] if you want to do it
or not but uh after seeing more of this
like I that was when I thought he was
just talking about me but hearing him
see seeing him talk about Ethan and
everything too I was just like all right
I'm not getting involved in this because
it's never gonna end this is not a bit
Yeah in fact
when it is a bit he says it's not a bit
yeah he you guys remember he got all
butt hurt about the chair thing which he
continues to bring up but here let's
continue about the AV thing there's more
than a bit
if he had trained he streamed we saw him
he streamed every day he did a 48-hour
stream two weeks before the fight why
are you bitter you won he sounds bitter
but first of all that's such [__]
bro you can stream and train you're not
training 24 hours a day the stream that
he's talking about I left twice during
that stream to go work out and I started
right after I worked out that's awesome
by the way he says you were throwing
windmills that's not true and by the way
his form was not [__] like that
amazing we both looked like [__] I mean
let me straight like we both it happens
but yeah we both looked I wasn't used to
dealing with a fighter like him and he
has a weird style as well we both look
like ass I mean it's a YouTube boxing
match yeah he's not that serious but you
know what it makes sense that he he he's
saying I should have tried harder but
you won maybe that is why I lost maybe I
shouldn't whatever you want to say just
take it take the win you won bro take
the dub you won
it's not a grudge match damn
when I was like in the thick of it
so
I think that's why he didn't do his good
because he would put more effort into
streaming this year leading up to the
fight than he did training
I think he could have been better if he
had trained as hard as I did
well to be fair you have literally
nothing going on except for this so
not as easy for him to train as hard as
you theoretically well and to be honest
I think I trained a lot more than him
too I think he started the last few
months while I was doing it long term
because he was traveling and stuff but
yeah whatever this this
this claim that you didn't train is so
stupid bro it's just it's insulting yeah
to a lot of people yeah you trained your
ass off dude I put while doing a
full-time job which his ass doesn't have
by the way yeah
I would wake up at 6am go running I
worked with Ian's coach Michael Briggs
the whole time and then after and he
would send me a new plan every Monday
and then after work I'd go straight to
the gym and depending on when the show
ended I'd either train there for two
maybe two and a half hours yeah
we disabled chat by the way because
I don't want they were I just turned it
off because everybody was already
arguing with each other in there yeah
it's sometimes it's better it's better
just turn it off while we talk about
things like this so it doesn't get all
heated
uh but yeah here we go
but I mean it's all hypothetical
definitely you know uh definitely I mean
I don't know I mean we don't know do we
anything about what he did no I don't
know I don't he never told me what he
actually did training wise but like
based on his streaming schedule and he
was live all the time immediately after
he'd get home from age three
that there was no time for him to be
training he did what the [__] it's just
not it's not it's all so not true I
would never stream it before a show day
either so that's how you know that it's
off what right well you trained you
trained before work usually didn't you
no I run before work and then after work
I I train until the gym closes I was
running out the door after the show to
go to the gym for the last six months it
feels like yeah you did not train twice
a day every single day like I did bro
you're not Floyd Mayweather
you're a washed up YouTuber why is he
doing this I don't know that's what's so
crazy to me well he's so salty about
what you won go ahead Dan
well I just think we should maybe take a
look at the stuff where he's talking
about you because I think the stuff
about you explain I don't think he's
saying any of this about AB if he wasn't
so mad at you right okay so let's finish
this and then we'll we can address why
he's I guess angry although it's super
unfair for him to turn it on UAB but I
don't even know if that's why he's doing
it yeah that's why I was able to take
headshots for hours
because
that's what I trained for didn't look
like it buddy
that man was scared as [__] this man
trained to get head shots for hours okay
I'd like to see the training how do you
prep for that just homies punching you
in the head maybe that explains why your
emotions are so unregulated well it must
have not been that hard if I was the
hardest that ever hit right he right
I'll have you know that I had my friends
punch me in the head a thousand times a
day in preparation for this fight
and it has left no lasting effects on my
brain I'm pissed off for no [__]
reason
interesting
that was the gentleman who holds the
world record for the most walnuts
smashed without forehead right right
right right right right yep right I
recognize that sound bite anymore thank
you all right a little deep cut ladies
and gentlemen
thank you
I don't know it doesn't really matter
ultimately
baby is doing really One streaming I'm
happy for him I'm very very he seems
jealous you need yeah let this I forgot
about this part yeah I'm glad it's going
well
neither of us are boxers neither of us
really want to be boxers
I do
I have a psychotic urge to win and I
will do whatever it takes to win so I
think that's why I did win
and maybe I don't think really has that
as much because it's not that important
to him which is understandable it
shouldn't be when you're internet
Entertainer
plus this game looks kind of Fire
what game is that does anyone know it
looks like Ratchet and Clank maybe oh oh
[__] I didn't realize it looks so good
this new one I'm not totally positive
that's the game I mean he got he did
pretty well out of creative class didn't
he really yeah he got a ton of new
viewers he's got Crazy Subs dude it all
worked out he's so jealous of that's
what this is all about I I don't I don't
know this is I didn't even know he was
trying to be a streamer I in my video I
put out yesterday I randomly threw in
the most random ass clip about him just
to plug his twitch
for no reason I just I don't know this
is all so [__] bizarre to me
holy [__] he's so
oh my god dude
oh brother imagine I won
hey I don't know you wanna I mean guys
ghosts uh
I apparently go sub to Dad you know
Amazon Prime dad
let's get let's
that's all that matters at the end of
the day right
good job baby by the way apparently
you're crushing it so are this dude
can't even [__] live stream
good for you
for him I won but I still have uh do you
think possibly dad that your personality
has anything to do with the reason why
okay so maybe I'm being too but I mean
what is this okay I'm sorry I even be
too mean okay wait till you see what he
says about me you know what you know
what the problem is though we're
definitely not me oh more than you did
have I do have more yeah this man just
thinks people he's just entitled for
people to watch him stream just why like
you have to at least do something that
people want to watch
but okay let's watch what he said about
me and I guess maybe I gotta
here
okay
maybe just posted his credit Clash video
did you want to watch it yeah
maybe I don't really care
I'm so over greater gosh right now all
right
you won bro
you had a triumphant Victory everyone
was loving it the entrance was awesome
there was huge dubs for you
it's sick so stressful H3 audience
really made it like not fun and
stressful
so I know this is stressful in so many
ways I know there's people in Asia
audience are like nice but there was a
lot of lousy crap that I'm like yeah and
even after the fight when it was proven
yep yep
I think that's just people dancer isn't
it and and the cult like
um
what is he talking about that we were
getting like we were getting kind of
riled up
we some people were like I don't think
it was a lot some people were like yo
dad played dirty and by the way we made
it very clear we're like listen that was
a legit when it wasn't dirty AB was
clinching to
so we questioned it for a second during
the live stream and we all clearly
didn't know the rules and then as the
live stream kept going we were like oh
clearly everybody's doing it yeah yeah
but even before the fight every comment
that was in support of me he was
responding to these people had one like
if even and he's responding saying oh
you'll see you'll see like in just I
don't know he's very defensive he's two
in the weeds because
I don't know I usually see a lot of
overwhelming support and love for Dad
yeah our own audience a lot of people
say I love you baby but dad's gonna win
it's like okay I
whatever
also it's a competitive sport yeah
like there's gonna be trash talking and
stuff like you but he's the one once
again into the WWE bro he's the one that
comes to the weigh-in with the picture
of ab's grave on his underwear like yeah
that's another thing yeah he has merch
with my gravestone on it like why why do
you get to dictate what's a bit and
what's not a bit yeah I don't understand
that exactly
the way that they are some of them most
of them
but unfortunately
the trolls and the mean people have the
loudest voices there's yeah okay
I mean it's also just the way the actual
full actual H3 crew react reacted
they were like incredibly mean to me
grow up bro dude they were watching
someone they're with every single day of
their lives fight you did the same thing
last year to Brett and possibly be very
injured I was really worried about him I
was really worried
and by the way again it's like dude grow
up we meet I immediately retracted it we
need to play Baby time for Dad
actually turned out to be the kid right
baby Barnett
and you know
[Music]
I don't know it's such a weird situation
well and the only reason I'm listen
he knew that this is what would happen
because this always happens whenever he
just started to get tons of traction on
our subreddit and then it becomes a
thing
you know
and then keemstar makes a three-part
documentary about how I destroyed Dad's
life or something like that you know
after the fight
when I was saying nice things about them
they were just ignorantly rude and
horrible
just because I won I wasn't that serious
it's also I would like to add we
couldn't hear his speech afterwards
because we were all talking and texting
and we lowered it because we were trying
to figure out what was happening with a
B yeah I was afraid we thought our
friend was dying so we weren't we
weren't blatantly is that okay Dad one
thing that was playing we did we
genuinely didn't hear it happen I
thought he had ruptured an organ and he
was dying dad is that okay with you
is that what he's referring to that we
muted after we saw a b get really
injured that seems to be what he's
[__] insane what the hell what
because all I remember is Ethan tweeting
that uh he was proud of dad and he's a
dad fan and then after when we were on
the show on Monday just saying nice
things about him so
yeah there must be what he's talking
about because I I saw he was upset so I
was like I want to make it clear
that that is family we like that we love
Dad
but uh I don't know what he wants me to
do Beyond I don't know what more he
wants
and it was like all right this is this
is how you really are okay you weren't
like this the hondar they didn't
actually get the hundar they never
hundar does not we talked so much [__]
on hondar and it was playful and it was
fine because hondar
understood that I mean he came on the
show right after and it was all good
Zach called him [__] boy Brett for like
it was [__] boy Brett on this show like
we were always [__] on but again
hundar
you you got that it was a bit yeah but
you're the one that's that's talking
[__] Bro right you're the one that's
[__] saying his name ten thousand
times with the with the gravestone do
you not understand like you were engaged
in this pandar also redeemed himself
this is stupid but he walked out to
Slayer for his entrance and it was
pretty [__] badass yeah
Slayer hundar
play
Beast Boy they didn't act like that the
hondar they never invited me on the show
Ethan just kept always saying oh we
gotta get Dad to call in okay first of
all
you are not entitled to be on my show
okay
you can come on the show if I want you
to come on the show
that being said
we did invite you on the show yeah it's
just what and and he said no
and he's been on the show previously
he's been on this show multiple times I
don't I don't know if we've said that
publicly but he said he didn't want to
come on yeah you could say no I invited
him on he said and he was scheduled to
call in he was still traveling at the
time
and obviously we got into the fight that
we're talking about that on Monday Abe
was here Dad was still traveling of
course we wanted to talk about it on
Monday
he was still traveling so we said dad
call in
he was meant to call in and then he sent
a b a text saying you know what I
don't think uh
I don't think I want to call in I guess
because he's so upset
so like why would you say I didn't
invite you bro and again not that I owe
you that anyway
me on the show Ethan just kept always
saying oh we gotta get Dad to call in
hondar was invited dude you said no
he's acting like it was an empty invite
we literally had three people message
him to tell try to get him to call in
call in Honduras was invited on the show
to chat and hang out I wasn't
okay well maybe we maybe I like hondar
more than you
but that's my but I'm that's my right
self-fulfilling prophecy too right like
you know but that being said we did
invite you that's the crazy part we did
you know
I'm entitled to [__] this is my
goddamn show I can invite hondar on and
you not if I want but we did invite you
just to be clear I was only said call in
so that they could do damage control
because they were so mean to me damage
control bro
I was just trying to be nice
because you know after the first chair
Fiasco Dad Dad kind of rubbed me wrong
after the whole first chair incident
where we were doing this bit and then
he's like the guys really are mean about
the chair thing
and that turned into a whole mini drama
uh
so I've been a little bit skeptical
because they were so mean to me they had
to be nice to me after and I was never
offered to even go on the show I mean it
wasn't damage control this it was just
we're just trying to be nice I wanted
that I just want to make sure he was you
know
why does he keep saying something that's
so easily disproven like this is
honestly weird
like him saying they never invited me to
go on the show like
you know how DMS work right like we we
have the receipts I think he's trying to
argue that we can get an in-person
invite he wasn't here a month he was out
of the state yeah
he wasn't here you were here on Monday
yeah it's kind of a Hot Topic
did you want me to what did you want me
to hold my show for you Dad
as apparently he is the rightful uh
dictator of what should and shouldn't be
on our show or offer to even go on the
show into the studio
so it's like all right dude you're just
trying to cover yourself and you were
like super mean to me this year
for some reason and you weren't ever
like that to hug hundar the whole year
last year they were not that mean to
hondar at all like he was they weren't
even like making jokes about me they
were just being they're saying Fu and
they're just saying straight up insults
was no joke at all I don't know I could
probably put like a 30 minute
compilation of us talking mad [__] on
hondar like you're just wrong you're
wrong I don't know what he's talking
about we were saying we were just mean
with no punchline
the one who was saying he was gonna kill
a bee again is oh God after the first
chair thing that went kind of sideways I
was like okay he's obviously sensitive
and stuff so I'm just gonna be straight
I'm not gonna do any stick and stuff
and uh so I'm not really sure what he's
talking about all and it was just
why am I even like associating with
these people that are just like so
uncreative and so uncreative just
randomly negative hold the phone
Skittles man
don't call me uncreative
I'll have you know
that uh
at behind this curtain I was ready to
have a doctor figure me in the [__]
now you want to call me uncreative I've
never seen that on YouTube have you but
they're performing
why don't you make that another 20th
Skittle commercial talk to me about
uncreative Dad
mm-hmm
finger hunger
I got creativity coming out my ass
so bad that I need a doctor to check it
on the show live thank you
see that UFO oh creative
come on
be mean to me also let's compare his
streaming set of Tears a B I mean yours
is a lot cooler oh mine is [__] dope
that's what I'm saying you know there's
a reason people like your stream it's
like more than his
it was stupid I was like this is dumbs
I'm not involved with any of this
anymore I'm over it so that's how I feel
right now I'm kind of like yep I won I
won fair and we all said that crap they
said I don't even care about moving on
that's so that's where I'm sitting right
that's where I feel right now how I feel
right now
fair enough so there we go whatever
yeah this game looks it was just sick
though this is Clank yeah Ratchet and
Clank rips apart is that a multiplayer
game or is it all oh it is a multiplayer
game I think you could Co-op it oh damn
okay clanks
game
clinks is out there
drift apart
a rift apart Ratchet
and Clank
I gotta look up I want to Mark mother's
bomb made the soundtrack
who's that he's the main dude from Devo
who's that
I'm with you I'll tell you after the
show he does a lot up for ta he doesn't
like composing for TV and games and
stuff uh
thanks for the game recommendation
though
pretty good reviews on that too
I wonder if you could play it on the um
steam deck it's like it's a PS5 only oh
yeah that could be good though I have a
PS5
okay so something something did come out
of this there you go yeah yeah okay I'm
excited to play
uh Plank and Ratchet
something like that something about a
rift
a bit from the beginning there was
supposed to be a chair bit that he
straight up purposefully
ruined we're all about the [__] chair
again
I don't even know how to talk about the
chair thing it's so CR it's so crazy to
me that this chair thing
I'm rude
the older's gonna yell at me any second
now to be like stop you're gonna get
you're going to bring in unnecessary
drama to your life which is probably
true but there was a a bit that they
approved listen if nobody was posting
this on subreddit I wouldn't care to
respond to it right
they talked about behind the scenes when
I brought when I was gonna do the chair
bit and Ethan decided to completely
change the bit and not talk to me or
anyone about it and then I got
what was the bit
what was the bit in his mind do you
think
okay super mega
it all started with a song going on
super Mega's podcast right and they gave
him a tiny chair and it was funny and
then Ethan as a joke they sent Ethan a
tiny chair and this was all
a super mega Hassan H3 thing right and
then Dad
decides oh I want to be part of this I'm
going to also send you a chair and this
is going to be the greatest chair ever
right that's like the bit but you
understand like the bit was that they
sent this crappy chair and
Ethan acted all offended and destroyed
it or or shot on it or whatever hold the
phone though right because he did not
send me
some Ethan Allen that's what I was about
to say he sent us a bunch of random crap
from Amazon right unassembled I'm gonna
send it which is fine and we said we
were going to assemble it yeah we
assemble it I wanna I wanna say that but
we didn't know what was arriving he said
he said he could do it or because he was
busy with something or if we we could do
it if we wanted to and I said and I
asked the crew and we said yeah we could
do it yeah because I thought yeah it
would be like you know an Ikea thing
right but this this is where I totally
lose the plot here what was the bit in
his mind so I'm pretty sure it was super
mega offended Ethan right and then dad
wanted to send a nice gesture but it was
sending a skinny chair did he not
understand that that was a joke like the
super mega hold on hold on do we have
the what the leftovers of that chair
because the the ingredients included to
make this chair was like duct tape
comically rubber human feet like a torn
apart chair I mean this thing was
objectively like dog [__] it was wrong
that's what I like that's why I'm lost
like wasn't the bit that you sent us a
crappy chair too like I I think there
were like memes on his channel and
that's what made it confusing like the
duct tape I guess is a meme on his
channel it's [__] there we didn't
understand so it just looked like you're
still not happy about that it's not nice
yeah it doesn't yeah it's not like he
sent me like a a G-Force 10 000 gamer
chair and I like burned it right I mean
that would have been obviously a
different bit and then so he sent that
and we talked about it and then he came
this get up right this is it this is
what he sent me you guys this is what he
sent me that was so nice that I was I
was supposed to have reverence and love
for so who didn't get the bit here us or
or dad he said hold on let me go back
and you guys can watch what he says over
this picture
the scenes when I brought when I was
going to do the chair bit and Ethan
decided to completely change the bit and
not talk to me or anyone about it and
then I got forced into doing this weird
chair bit he started which started the
whole relationship with me and them off
on the wrong foot and let me go back a
little further we talk about how nice
the chair is
so there you go whatever by the way my
intention with that was to set him up
for like a nice little riff Tiff for tat
like I was gonna Cloud him up we were
having like this whole chair Feud I did
a whole segment on the show about it for
him right I didn't ask him to send me a
[__] chair you know I mean he's just
like hey yo include me in your show and
I'm like okay cool let's do it you know
like he's not [__] entitled to
oh this is from an hour ago so no no no
no no no I think this was right after
you broke the chair
yeah this chair this is the chair he's
talking about
Ethan ruined the bit from the beginning
that he straight up purposefully
ruined bro this chair
this is where I start to just not even
be mad but just like what but like
what's going on over there a bit that
they approved they talked about behind
the scenes when I brought when I was
gonna do the chair bit
decided to completely change the bit and
not talk to me or anyone about it and
then I got forced into doing this weird
chair bit he started which started the
whole relationship with me and them off
on the wrong foot I I suppose he wanted
me to to sit and with reverence and love
for this incredible chair which couldn't
even support my weight it breaks if you
sit in it
so like what did what am I as an
Entertainer
supposed to make of this chair
and again I guess he came and built it
right he sent us all these separate
[__] things from like an Amazon order
and expected us to know how to build
this firm
even if he had instructions it's just
again like that's fine but like
what
he says like there was communication
about this beforehand and we decided to
change the plan
like what in his mind were we supposed
to like praise this chair and be like oh
this is the greatest thing ever yeah it
didn't really make sense I think we got
a little confused actually if you go
back into the episode we're a little
confused about what's going on
and after the fact he then did a live
stream where he said a bunch of stuff
talking bad and and then you reached out
to him I believe Ethan I believe you
guys talked about it and he's like oh I
didn't know it was going to go that way
but I guess now yeah like he just played
up I want to play it up like I'm the sad
oh yeah he told me it was a bit yeah I
was like bro are you seriously upset
about this and he's like no it's just a
bit but they I was just doing a bit
where but people took it the wrong way
and they ruined it but he's actually not
doing a bit then or now
yeah right so you even tried to address
it with him privately and he deflected
in what either he's lying then or he's
lying now well and then also before we
went on this live here today I once
again wanted to reach out to him uh
personally to ask him what's the deal
and he unfollowed me on Twitter
so he's pissed
and you know again like both times I
tried to work it out with him behind the
scenes this time too he just unfollowed
me
um
which means I can't message him
but yes this should be
this really should be in the uh
where's all the crown jewels at
uh Tower of London oh it's in the Tower
of London I think
that was in some Museum the Tower of
London is basically a museum I believe
yeah
this belongs of London yes with all the
greatest gems humanity is ever on earth
the fact that this Fair chair uh a
testament to the peak of human
engineering while sucking a smoker was
disrespected by me is a crime punishable
by death I'm dreaming of my next Tucker
what would you think if you got this
chair you were meant to do with it
I mean especially when it's a follow-up
again to super mega also sending a
crappy chair like it felt like a
continuation of that joke to be honest
super super mega 27's share was cooler
was better it was nicer and correct me
if I'm wrong so he sent us all the stuff
and we talked about the show and we're
like Dad what the [__] why'd you send us
all the stuff and like play it up like
what are we supposed to do with all this
yeah and then he came here
right A B to pick up the stuff so that
he could assemble it yes and so when he
came here
that was my first time meeting him in
person I walked right up to him
introduced myself I was happy to see him
legitimately because we had talked to
him a bunch and I said and I said to him
you know this is all just like a joke
right we're just like [__] around he
was fully in
on that the fact that it was it's like
pro wrestling we were like playing it up
and by the way we knew a b was fighting
dad at that point but it wasn't publicly
known and so it was all kind of building
up towards this rivalry no we knew that
far back I don't remember when he came
to the office we did yeah okay yeah
[Music]
yeah when you're like hey you know this
is just a joke right was after he had
like was venting on Twitter about what
an [__] I am
I don't think so
I I forget that part I just know that
you know we have on the show we were
like leaning into this like that what
the [__] why'd you do this so I wanted
to make it clear when it came in that
like we're just [__] around and I did
we shot him in a video where like
everyone was being mean to him right and
then that was the day we shot that video
where he came to pick it up and we're
like Dad what the [__] I mean we have
that footage he's like completely in on
the joke he's laughing with us like when
we cut and everything it's like and he
if she even suggests be meaner to me
here right yeah he said he said yeah be
meaner to me at this point he says push
me down the stairs or something right
right so like that was
right and at that point
it seemed like it was all good like it
all came out of left field and it yeah
and when he did that live stream the
first time we were talking about well do
we want to bring this up then and we
didn't want to you know bring him any
hate we're just like no talk to him
privately and you guys supposedly
figured it out but now he's doing this
again so it's wild to me
I think he's going back to the first
thing he got mad at me about that I
thought we'd figured out and he said no
it's all a bet and now he's back
I knew it wasn't a bit then
it was too real
is this all a bit is this all a bit
usually people promote fights uh with
fake beefs before the fight right that's
right that's true I mean there's it's
not very funny to like
demean you his his uh opponent after the
fight
that's just corn I mean it sucks you
know I I go to a very serious gym I felt
like I was like even lucky to be there
because I was the least talented there
and they still worked with me and I feel
like I let so many people down you know
and uh it sucks it sucks to lose I other
fans I felt horrible they drove all the
way from Michigan some you know even
further drove to come see me and I gave
them one round I felt horrible about
that so for him to say [__] like I
didn't take it serious it's just like
well maybe you didn't apologize to the
most important person affected right Dad
right
as you were dying there as a ref of a
ruptured liver um
you should have crawled over to Dad as
he
[Music]
hopped on the
the Ring Side ropes
and begged for his forgiveness you
should have kissed his feet and said dad
with my dying breath I have this to say
to you forgive me
I'm sorry about your dad passed
yeah please please
forgive me
say anything about it because it was I
was just trying to go along with
whatever was happening but Ethan in my
opinion
it was nine months before it was ever
going to be announced that that a b and
I bro we were doing like a whole plot
line it was going to be great for you
it was going to be so good for you again
this guy wants to be in the WWE and like
he's gonna get so butter yeah I imagine
I don't understand like like have you
ever watched wrestling do you know what
a heel is like you're playing a heel but
then getting upset when people are
treating you like a heel I love the idea
of him like behind the scenes getting
super mad about some bits out on WWE yo
I want to say bro that was super mean
what you said to me out there and I know
like you're doing shtick but honestly
dude that really hurt my feelings can
you imagine what their reaction
ugh I were fighting and he just started
being randomly rude to me and people
were like wait why are you being mean to
Dad I thought dad was a friend of the
show so because of Ethan because he's in
my opinion an actual crappy person and I
used to like him I used to defend him
and I was I'll be fine without you
defending me Dad and you know what can I
just say well he's well he's saying that
the reason you could have wrote out on
him a long time ago we got the footage
we got the text but you didn't want to
put his ass on blast like that you were
protecting him by taking all that heat
because it was weird for him for you not
to be able to just acknowledge it
publicly why this makes no [__] sense
and it sort of seems like he took
advantage of that see a lot of people
don't like Ethan and that's totally fine
you know oh come on Charlie you do damn
oh damn no now dad's among the ranks of
the
the Fallen fans oh now I must defend
Ethan Klein oh no I don't want to no no
no no
oh [__] not the quartering
um and you guys know that I listen
it's not easy for me to let someone say
that kind of [__] about me and just let
it slide but I did I did yeah it's not
easy because I'm [__] crazy like that
you guys know
and even now I'm showing a little bit of
restraint trust me I know
you know we could pull the receipts but
that's just Petty and silly
pull the footage
of you laughing asking the guys to push
you down the stairs that's stupid it's
silly it's Petty we don't need to do
that
[Music]
I could pull the text messages that you
sent me at 3am threatening my family no
I'm just kidding that didn't happen
anyway yeah he says I'm a crappy person
it's like come on dude seriously and I
used to like him I used to defend him
actual crappy person and I used to like
him I used to defend him
and I was like all right I get why
people complain about him now oh he's a
full he's a totally Fallen fan man he's
like I'm with the haters 100 now I get
it
they was right the whole time keemstar
my DMs are open baby
[Music]
this was being really unnecessarily mean
to me because he thought it was a funny
bit but yet no one knew why and the bit
for the chair was a completely different
thing it was a nice gesture for me okay
let me open the chair again hold on hold
on
okay there it is
here he goes the this wonderful gesture
for the chair was a completely different
thing it was a nice gesture for me to
the joke was dad was trying to be nice
because eight Mega 64 was mean that's
was mean to Ethan I'm trying to send a
funny innocent kind gesture setting this
chair he twisted it just to make it so
that he could start hating on me and it
made no sense it was the dumbest bit
ever because there was no reason for us
to be feuding and that was the beginning
of a disastrous back and forth between
stage three there was no back and forth
I mean it was just you being a dick
and me trying to calm things behind the
scenes you know
but now we got it back and forth
well there's not gonna be any back and
forth I just want to address this once
but uh just let me know
if you want this to go to the London
Tower or
the pal the Versailles
any you know major museums who if you
have any takers let me know I'll send it
to them
understand this is a collectible
[Music]
highly prized
the nicest thing anyone's ever done for
me frankly
as a person who prides themselves
okay hold on hold on hold on
is this for real is this real okay so
this this I guess makes sense this is
King Charles it's a replica of his chair
that makes sense okay so maybe I was
disrespectful
[Music]
okay that makes sense
I'm sorry
I apologize
that's my bad and
WWE style beefs okay this is my favorite
part I do
feuds and
WWE style beefs
that's like what I do it's what he does
professionally with Dolph Ziggler
Ethan is just kind of an idiot and this
man is this is what he does it's who he
is
that's what I do
so [__] me I guess for getting that
wrong himself only and does not make
other people look good because he can't
take any insults out oh ela's pissed now
Ela said there's no chat but I want to
leave a comment
she said how dare he say Ethan's a
crappy person can you say that I'm
pissed hearing that they better fear Ela
thank you Mila actually Ila you're the
great thank you I love you I agree it
was kind of shocking but uh
stay down [__] baby
you pissed off Eagle now dude you're
[__] you're crazy going that route
boy you don't want to mess with me
thank you ELO
I love you so much you're so beautiful
it's stunning and the photos you did
yesterday are awesome
thank you
and you're about to give birth to
another beautiful third child and I'm so
excited and proud of you by the way if
you're not pregnant yet it's not an
announcement
Ela said I interpreted the chair bit
exactly the same as Ethan yeah I mean I
saw the whole thing playing out it was
it for me I saw it all I was like yo I'm
gonna hook that up it's gonna be a great
bit
a [__] Dozer
anyways I'll stop talking about it
because I'm like
gonna just start rambling
so any drugs so H3 whatever dude I know
the audience is nice but Ethan is pretty
stupid in my opinion and no one ever
tells him that because he's the boss and
they have to just they tell me that all
the time dude
I wish they'd say it less I wish they'd
say it less
a b we had a call a meeting yesterday
and Amy goes listen dude I gotta break
it too
you have to stop using chat GPT too much
he's right after I said that I was like
please let someone [__] back me up
and thankfully Dan backed me up but oh
man no I went into it and then I would
back you up on it dp's up
I get called like an idiot by these guys
daily and I'm I think it's awesome that
we have a workplace where you're open to
letting everybody [__] on you all the
time so thank you
don't push it don't push don't push no
I'm kidding
I'm a radical communicator
I appreciate people who speak frankly
and openly
because then how I mean how else are you
supposed to
know anything
I don't want to be surrounded by yes
people men who don't [__] tell me
when something you know what I mean it's
wrong
exactly I don't want you to sound like
that baby
this is pretty stupid in my opinion and
no one ever tells him that because he's
the boss and they have to just
make everything better for him and let
him say stupid things and then why do
you presume to know so much about what
happens here like whatever fake ass fan
fake fan dad
act like he didn't do anything dumb when
he's actually
is he talking about the chair thing he
thinks that everybody
does take responsibility for his actions
every once in a while
yeah anyway
the only thing I can think he may be
referring to is because after when we
were texting I was like oh yeah sorry I
didn't know it was going to go like that
but yeah it just kind of happens on the
show but that was because I did tell him
that we would build it and then when we
got it it was like what the [__] is this
but that's the only angle I could think
he's remember I was doing improvisation
I was I was riffing I was rapping I just
didn't want to think like yeah I was
like I intended on [__] with him but
I don't know I was riffing and I was
rapping brother
and so that's that so I just want to
address this one time don't give Dad a
hard time you know but uh
what can I do yeah you have to and like
At first I was angry that's why I was
telling all right you think I didn't get
training let's go Spar wherever you want
at first but then after like seeing more
of the footage I just I kind of felt I
don't know something something's not
right so you know I wish him the best
and uh
yeah
he's going through something I guess
yeah but like the ironic part was like
I'm I was I mean I'm still am excited to
watch him fight again he's an
interesting fighter and now that he's
not up against you
uh obviously it'd be a lot more
enjoyable experience you don't have to
worry about you dying which I thought
you were
uh but uh I mean you know good luck in
your boxing career
and uh I will be watching that uh to
your to your next fight
um
I don't know about the WWE future though
I gotta say
probably not the best protocol
in terms of
handling beef thank you could you
possibly be doing all this to to get on
the keemstar card or something
I just thought of that I don't know is
he that uh that well keemstar would
would hire him anyway he doesn't need to
do anything kimster is desperate as [__]
he's probably on the phone with him
right now
what's that he's probably on the phone
with him right now probably Kim's called
his ass yeah I came called him already
he's like hey man I was just watching
the show no let me go with keemstar [__]
I don't know I mean if he does something
good for your career good keemstar his
promotion company as that one guy I love
saw uh
yeah I love that guy man he's awesome
and yeah he's signed with keemstar's
promotion company for some [__]
reason wow but that's surprising it is
it's very surprising but uh okay if he
could do something for you then God
bless obviously I can't do anything for
you
don't harass dad leave dad alone we're
all just going to look forward to his
next fight and uh
wish him all the best
this is my obligation to respond
yeah
I I I still love Dad and it's David
dobrik
it's the only one said about David
dobrik I'm not mad I'm just disappointed
[Music]
that sounds [__] CR I love that
do I sound like him
close yeah
[Music]
all right bring the chat back okay you
guys are off timeout now after talking
about Dad now let's go laugh on uh
Stephen Crowder's uh
speaking of single [__] divorced
loser-ass dads
[Applause]
oh me free be free people in the chat
freedom freedom I turn it on it's not
maybe I have to refresh before it'll
show up again and they're back there um
they're back I just want to say one last
thing head to the bathroom
I guess it's okay to be a sore loser now
but
I did not feel a single hit of his until
I sat down that's all I'm saying that's
all I'm saying well listen you got not
not to say that either one of you was
hitting hard or not you were both
hitting pretty hard no he got me with
something because it took me out he won
but I mean it's adrenaline okay
you guys are all hyped up on adrenaline
you probably don't feel anything you
know yeah
there it is welcome back everybody
all right so let's talk about oh there's
a few things at the top of the show here
that are fun and then I want to talk
about Crowder's loser dumbass loser
idiot his video about this is so so good
yeah
this man is straight up
the only reason I got divorced is
because the state of Texas allows women
to leave their husbands
that's a pretty crazy thing to say
actually maybe let's just watch it and
then I'll do top of the show stuff after
so sounds like a copy pasta I so want
you to watch this one video okay fine
what do you got me I'll watch whatever
you want what do you got well there's
actually a few because the the new PMP
video Let's watch PNP let's celebrate it
this is like one of my all-time
favorites also he put out a few uh new
videos I noticed the uh the drink
whiskey like a Pros I was about to say
that it's Prime like old age three
content so I've seen that video so many
times and I try to always try to always
think about what to do with that with
that video and I never
oh you're familiar yeah yeah oh okay I
was trying to always work out how to use
it but I never really found a way we'll
watch it so here's our boy PNP back at
it again at a court with my client we
absolutely crushed his case look this
was a second time DUI yeah he was
leaving the Rufus du Sol concert at the
Hollywood Bowl had some drinks had a
dirty dog a delicious blizzy and this
man is so happy
David is such a good guy though I
he has helped out our nanny so much I
don't know how much have I said this on
the show I don't remember you've
mentioned it uh you mentioned it last
week I turned to David because there was
nobody else
and he [__] went to town and resolved
this for her it was incredible King this
man he's he's so dedicated to doing the
good job for his clients
that he's willing to do anything you
know what I'm saying
no
use your imagination
cares about his clients got it
just put it that way and leave it there
car with an angry person in it who
called the police I love that she's
angry yeah I want to run around with an
angry person oh a bunch of losers in the
car who are pissed and they got
rear-ended by a drunk driver
oh yeah [__] David he's a real
Advocate I mean that's his job
right yeah and uh allegedly he got
behind the wheel
car with an angry person in it the
police angry idiot
it was at issue whether or not he was
really the driver right it was his
girlfriend driving police never even
asked him if he drove his own car this
is so slick David he always finds the
angle he's like did you ask who was
driving the car
right they're like well you were in the
seat no no no no no we're on the police
Port please report does it say
I was driving the car and that [__]
Works apparently in court and he was
just standing there talking to the
police doing the field sobriety test
never even asked stem and the other
driver you know his ass was driving that
car that's the best part like it's
obvious we all know that he's don't know
that for sure
oh he was driving that car we don't know
this man was driving that car
[Laughter]
[Music]
he did that
well why the [__] would he be out doing
a field sobriety test and like you know
I mean if he wasn't driving
but they didn't ask they didn't ask
that's the point I just think it's funny
it was it was was kind of iffy too so
the prosecutors really gave us a hard
time on this case they wrote a
three-page internal memo on this case
and ultimately sided with us and now
he's gonna only get a reckless driving
all right
only getting a reckless driving one year
of probation instead of three year
instead of five years that they wanted
him to have because it was the second
time DUI
0.23 BAC very high blood alcohol content
with collision and then of the day they
couldn't really really prove it 100 it
was too risky if they went to trial they
probably you know they could have you
know there's a roll of the dice
that's awesome that's the best part that
is the best part they both are like if
they went to trial
yeah wouldn't have been good for you
right right
this man was driving that car boy and he
was drunk as hell too PNP is made of
magic he's just so crazy you know she's
special he doesn't there's no judgment
he's just there to be your advocate
and we love that firm
and I feel so much safer knowing that
this guy's back on the road
yeah right where he belongs baby
he's right
outspoken and straightforward kind of
guy you really want to contact him and
get you know get him on your side trust
me that's right not regret it all right
let's go I'm always the powerful let's
go at the end of that one he was proud
of that one he gets another one
I always wonder how does it do like this
fine David you know what I mean
how does it happen Word of Mouth
referral codes
you think this guy's a fan I mean
because he was letting uh Gotham's
finest out even before we talked about
him
Gotham's finest
there's another new one here there's a
few new ones actually all right I'm
right outside of court with my great
client here uh look this was not an easy
one the police pulled her over for
speeding on the freeway they got her
going 88 on the fight fast uh they
smelled alcohol she did a breathalyzer
test came back
.12 I'm not familiar with the blood
alcohol 0.08 0.08 is is the legal limit
at least in California so one two is uh
uh 50 over the limit so it's probably
not like super drunk that's like it's
not like drinks it's not good but it's
but yeah I mean if you're driving 80 or
like half It's Like Crazy 88 is fast you
don't want to be drunk at that speed
yeah but that last homie was at .24 that
sounds very drunk
that's that's hammered let's go
well he crashed into a parked car so we
don't know if it was him
we don't know we don't know true it was
the ghost there's Reasonable Doubt there
I know no we don't know I have a theory
that David's only had one innocent
client because he had one video where he
said multiple times like this guy now
this guy's innocent ass [__] you guys
don't understand he's innocent is he's
never done that before yeah he's never
said that that's interesting that's
interesting too much wine sorry
fall content uh you know and she is on
her way to become a nurse this case
could have been extremely damaging to
her career but I'm proud proud to
announce that after working really hard
on this game we finally got a reckless
driving DUI dismissed reckless driving
one year of Probation and then we can
expunge it off her record how are you
feeling great thank you so much all
right you're you happy that you can uh
go to nursing school yes
all right let's go and just remember
David puts this camera on in their face
and doesn't because he wants to get him
candid right he doesn't give him a
chance to say no
love that he's a man dude nobody like
David in this whole product let's go
oh this one hit pretty hard I don't know
if we saw this one
I think we did actually all right we're
ready
uh we're on a third time DUI case dude
three times bro why are you smiling that
big yeah they got me again [__]
three times dude here we go again
fourth he had one more than 10 years
prior we were here on a motion for
military diversion uh he served in the
military he suffered a lot he was in a
firefight size Captain die oh okay even
exploded from an improvised wow you
exploded bro all right the way he's just
nodding what does that mean he's like
yup
[Laughter]
technically his fourth he had one more
than 10 years prior
he went like for military diversion uh
he's been nodding up and down he's
suffered a lot he was in a firefight
size Captain
exploded the knot is getting slower
the prosecutor fought us thought that he
wouldn't be eligible for treatment and
that treatment would do nothing for him
oh that's [__] up today we won and we
got our motion granted so after two
years the case is going to be dismissed
off his record and I'll note that we
even beat his DMV hearing yeah
expert witness to try to reverse
extrapolate please imagine him making
all those sounds and pmp's ear let's go
get a drink to celebrate yeah thank you
for your service thank you yeah
uh yeah he's demanded [__] Legend
what does it mean that he exploded
it sounds like he stepped on a landmine
he got hit by an IED most yeah he is
what that means like was in a yeah it
was in a truck or something he thought
that I mean he smiled at that moment
he's just happy he survived right that's
fair yeah yeah
there's a whole Pete Davidson drama uh
I'll let you know Olivia
uh he apparently pushed some old guy but
it seems like he was in the right if you
ask me this guy was harassing him I
guess
this guy was like following him all
night all up in his [__] touching him
putting his head on his shoulder like
dude what is your deal look at this and
you can see him getting annoyed I could
tell right like all night this guy was
following him
let me guess that again I mean it was
not like the hardest push he was just
like get the [__] away from me dude
I know that he was ignoring him which
is he was respectful and then he snapped
he did I mean he shouldn't have been
touching him in the first place
he didn't warn him before he hit him
with a push though he could have said
dude get the [__] yeah he may have he
may have already may have yeah he may
have whispered it or something because
again what I read was this guy was
harassed him all
yeah if there's more uh prior to this
too then it's more understandable for
him to kind of snap at him like that I
think it's fine I'm cool with it I'm
cool with it yeah
he didn't push him like to hurt him
because he could have he couldn't follow
through and sent him to the floor
it was really just said like dude stop
[__] touching me and the dude's not
even like trying to take a picture with
him he's just trying to be in the photos
and be in he's a weird he's doing weird
stuff yeah so okay we are absolving
acquitting
That's My Boy Peter Davidson
to Peter Davidson
we love Peter Davidson keep pushing old
creeps Pete
here's another David dobrik clip of him
uh pretending to Blind someone
no yep another one yep another one well
I guess you could you could
you could maybe debate if that was his
intention or not but I'll show it to you
tell me what you think it's pepper spray
gag spray this is in case anybody comes
oh shoot oh my God
I mean pepper spray someone in the eyes
at least it was water well yeah [__]
that'd be pretty wild
[Applause]
that David though brick man he is such a
prankster boy
he is such a prankster
that's like an old Bozo the Clown gag
with the squirting flower yeah exactly
gotcha
what's next the electrocuting handshake
Waka Waka
um
also elon's old got leaked which is kind
of interesting
maybe
but he was logged in and the picture he
posted yeah so I mean
I guess let's just give this disclaimer
there's no way to 100 prove it now given
all of the circumstances
I think that this is his alt you proved
it but I can't well definitively it's
pretty compelling so here's the picture
where
here he posted this photo
it's a little fuzzy but he posted a
picture of his
Twitter profile he was showing off how
many people were subbed him on the like
new like patreon membership thing that
they have on Twitter and by the way
there's 25
000 [__] suckers paying a billionaire
one of the richest people in the world
five dollars a month
for for his epic memes for doing what
exactly he posted epic memes
Kylie yeah so but there's a picture here
of another account he's logged into and
it's a picture of him as a baby that
isn't really you can't find anywhere
else on the internet not him as a baby
his son oh it's his son yes
which you can't find on the internet
elsewhere that is what leads me to think
it is him like because everything else
about this could have been somebody
because you know you can change your if
you're not verified or I guess that
doesn't exist anymore but if you don't
have Twitter blue
you can change your handle and stuff so
people are like well somebody might have
seen it and quickly just use the same
photo change the profile picture that
change their name and make it seem like
this is the account
um however
a lot of people try to find that image
on like reverse image search services
and it seemingly was nowhere online so
it seemed to be a personal photo of his
son that only Elon had which that's what
makes me think it's real but again you
can't
a hundred percent say
it's not a weird whiff or something
except from the AC I think they just
turned on the heater
oh oh okay that explains it
um come with that heat
so and it's not like incriminating it's
just downright weird it's very weird
this dude said bro had a net worth of 16
billion and risked it all for this the
grippy must have been unfathomable
unfathomable
Elon uh alt and when I say Elon alt it's
alleged alleged
I heart librarians
okay
it's a little weird I do make an ALT for
that
Satoshi had the idea right uh that's the
fabled creator of Bitcoin he said do you
like Japanese girls
it's just strange hey it's a weird thing
to throw out there very bizarre very
bizarre
and did you write that from your son's
Avatar okay it's a little [__] weird
it feels like we're in a nightclub and
the lice just turned on what nightclub
were you at Elon asked I wish I was old
enough to go to nightclubs they sound so
fun
that's where it starts to get
real weird
because he's like role-playing as his
own two-year-old son
uh
uh there's more let's see
uh Elon is responding to his own tweets
now
posted a picture of this Sam dude who
defrauded a bunch of people with that
yeah
with the title it's on PornHub it says
man [__] five million people at once
and then his alt said
is this a real peon video like porn
supposed to be like as if a kid typed
porn yeah is it like baby talk is he
doing the baby talk Point putting on
yeah because you know that that's like a
thing with like some alt-right people we
talked about on leftovers wait they talk
like where they like do like the weird
baby talk thing wait what my friends
where are my friends at and like no they
don't yeah dude we talked we talked
about it I remember but like you got to
show me a video talk to me baby I don't
believe you know they ride additionally
and and what's the purpose of sounding
like a child
or not even a child like a baby I
I don't know I I don't have the answer
on that because they want to seem like
they're not the pedos baby wants
if we sound like kids creepy kids they
won't think we're the pedos
man nothing hit like that Coke Zero dude
nothing in this world
pretty weird stuff huh
continuing on it was weird pretty cringy
uh I will finally turn three on May 4th
which is his son's birthday
I don't know right so he's like talking
as his son is this a real porn porn
video right
right
damn
yeah so I don't know if this is where it
started but I just was Googling around
and yeah I remember hearing about this
there was a
subreddit called friend world
and like they would all talk to hello
friend like and they talk about their
candies and like
it's just I don't know that's not what's
it called for the word yeah I mean it's
there's an overlap with that Community
for sure yeah
that is really [__] weird you guys
super weird
because they call themselves that people
with gripers that do that kind of [__]
yeah
that's pretty uh I don't know how that
that's that's how do you get people in
on that
come join our Reddit
griper The Forum where we talk to each
other like babies grown-ass men it's
weird man
all right well moving on we're almost to
the Crowder thing there's a couple more
things
uh this was a really good suggestion
from the subreddit
how to go back in time and prevent the
Bill Burr episode
or really to uh prevent any tragedy
right even to go back and prevent Adam
and Eve from eating the Apple
how Ethan should spend the 620k rewind
time I think this is genius I don't know
why we
I don't know why we didn't uh think of
this so that's 20 buttons so what if we
go 20 buttons back we can erase it all
if we just need more buttons I'm
assuming thousands of buttons it's like
an exponential thing like oh you think
so it would have to be because we have
like what like a 20 second delay or
whatever so if you just added all the 20
second delays that wouldn't that would
just be a few minutes but if you
multiplied it by 20 every time
all of a sudden
we're in business so yeah I mean we can
go all the way back we can button
ourselves out of existence Benjamin
Button
there it is so thank you for the
suggestion we're considering buying more
yeah yeah they're only 20 grand a pops
so
this was the video you guys wanted me to
watch yeah I've watched this video so
many times
trying to figure out how can I make a H3
video about it
and I never really was able to figure
out the right approach but it is a great
video I'll watch it
swirl it around as I said to you before
throw it out because you want to get rid
of any orders that are perhaps on the
lip of the glass so swirl it around
bring it up and say hello then you go
back Jed how are you and then you go
back to it
quite well yo this man is smelling the
straight whiskey like it's wine It's
gotta be gnarly I love it
that you know that doesn't smell good
thank you very much now remember get
into it don't go like this none of this
stuff you want to get right into it to
make sure that you're sure
how do you taste it don't knock it back
like a cowboy take the water but don't
just pick up a jug like this what you
need to do is to pick up a jug with your
finger in the water wow
he explains why finger in the water give
him time there's a method to the madness
why do you want to test
because many bottoman unfortunately
stick their jug under a hot time mistake
and therefore this is what ruins whiskey
six times I've now ruined my whiskey six
times twice in America once in France
once in Stockholm and twice in England
so you take the Still Water you put it
into the whiskey reduce it down to 35
alcohol 35 is the ideal strength for
really bringing out the whiskey in the
palette putting them out
[Music]
this man is an alcoholic
with class the class The Classy alcohol
this man is dead for sure also I'm
pretty sure he sounds like he's got
Scottish accent right yeah I hear that
yeah so I mean it might be fits the bill
they can pay the Whisk
scotch
yeah
absolutely fantastic if in fact I hadn't
added sufficient water what would happen
this is what would happen
your space would start grimishing it
would start changing because it was
affecting The Taste Buds and nephotizing
them so that's not what you need I
thought that that is what you give us
when I have a presentation finish at
night
I want to relax go into the bar there's
nothing more wonderful than the sound of
whiskey being poured by the barman into
a glass
just when I'm about to take the glass
from them to enjoy my whiskey this man
has just built this whole world around
just justifying him being an alcoholic
you know it's like yeah dude it's like a
dude with a heroin needle being like and
there's nothing better than the sound of
the needle filling up
I click it you gotta you gotta give it a
little squirt oh yeah make sure there's
no air in it the flick
I like to add a little bit of water to
My Heroine
for the taste and down down it and down
it goes oh yes and it's all about that
not about the part that I'm actually
just doing heroin
I'm probably insulting uh hobbyist
drinkers uh I your valid your hobby is
valid but he's been a whole career out
of it you are now I respect it
I mean
I'm just saying suddenly I hear this
other noise
[Applause]
but many bits
this is now scotch on the rocks this is
taking my whiskey ruining it with all
this ice in the olden days when there
was no ice Scots had to improvise so
what did they do they went to the
riverbeds they took the cold rocks have
been chilled by the mountain snows they
put that into the whiskey and that
chilled it and that's why we call it
scotch on the rocks all I'm saying to
you is this that cannot be why they call
it scotch on the rocks that actually
makes sense really well Ice is like
rocks
the name itself does it makes sense
already
uh I guess that's true but I have heard
about using cold uh stones to uh
to cool your alcohol I've got a rocks in
my uncle yeah you put rocks in your
alcohol it's like round rocks yeah like
big boys yeah on the Rocks is
what is the origin of that phrase
for cocktails
gp's up on the Rocks is a phrase used in
bartending to describe I know
like Trace backs to Mid 20th century
when ice became more readily available
the phrase likely stems from the visual
similarity between ice cubes and rocks
it's wrong the robot's wrong what does
it know about it continues before modern
refrigeration what where widespread ice
was a luxury oh so they go on
uh
I think you know okay all right Jeff BTC
agrees with me everybody's saying they
own whiskeys or like yeah I own Whiskey
Stones Whiskey Stones I never heard yeah
I've seen I've seen those before okay
great
yeah that makes sense because it doesn't
melt like ice so it doesn't water down
the alcohol but it still keeps it cool
yeah it makes it usable and it's
reusable
if you're ever in a bar and you want to
try and enjoy your whiskey this way
don't take it take hold of the barman
and show them what it's all about yeah
Chuck it away don't need it man that
dude set up a second camera for that I
love the dramatic players he's like get
that second camera ready don't take it
take hold of the barman and show him
what it's all about
you imagine going into a bar it's like
too much eyes
I would I mean yeah I'd like to drink
with him that's pretty dope
but I feel like every sip you take you'd
be like you're doing it wrong
you know
[Music]
well I'd like to do it right so all
right let's talk about crap the poor
unfortunate loser
idiot Stephen Crowder
[Music]
now we're we're probably the answer to
his question of why did my wife leave me
is in
his end of video itself right
which is interesting
um
here's the clip from yogurt and then I
had a hard time the rest of the weekend
here's a clip of crowder
who cannot stop talking about family
values and the importance of uh
families staying together
and talking about how black families are
the way they are like I don't know that
one single parent family's uh is ruining
black families and all kinds of crazy
[__] this man has dedicated his whole
[__] life to this image of him being
a good Christian heterosexual man
and just like all the other ones they
cannot stay married
how many times do these guys get married
man like they all get married like 10
times bro
they're the most
either they're just like
they must just be intolerable I mean
they must just be horrible I mean that's
really what it comes down to right
I mean yeah
or well in this case I mean he's gay so
that must have been awkward for her bye
to be fair to him oh he said he's bi
right
which again is great
bye
I have been living with a proverbial
boot on my neck for going on years now
uh this is important as we look back at
receipts this has been going on for
years
since 2021 I've been living through what
has increasingly been a horrendous
divorce now let me say on the outset to
be clear there is no infidelity any kind
of physical abuse at all on either side
and no this was not
my choice
do you find it interesting that you had
to say that like
he's like and just because I know
everybody's wondering
no I think that very much makes sense
because again he
has cultivated this image that like
divorce is uh terrible and weak part of
losers yeah and and as you'll see he
holds the belief that
um
no fault divorces which is when you can
get divorced you you don't need to agree
to be divorced and like one party can
divorce the other without the consent
um he thinks that that is a bad thing
which is really interesting and yeah I
mean it's really made the reaction to
all of this from uh his supporters has
made me realize uh a lot of Republicans
feel that way which is is that right so
his yeah his audience are like damn okay
well let's watch the video we haven't
gotten into it yet
any kind of physical abuse at all on
either side
and no this was not
uh my choice my then wife decided that
she didn't want to be married anymore
yeah dude you [__] suck
who's surprised man you suck you're a
douche you're an [__] you're hateful
you're a bigot and you probably think
about dudes when you have sex with her
and so you go soft when you have sex
with your wife you can't perform for her
because you're not attracted to women
which is cool
but you're also homophobic which is
what's ironic about that
uh
I suspect
uh if I can theorize
there was friction in the bedroom he's
totally he's totally um how do you call
it when you can't get it up
no
impotent I think he's totally important
yeah he's totally impotent this man he
he cannot get hard
and she starts to be like is it me
and he goes no baby no it's just I'm
under a lot of stress with work and you
know all this
but I have a year after year he can't
get it up and she starts to feel
immersive me am I ugly
does he not love me is he cheating on me
it's she keeps thinking is it me is it
me is it me is it me no baby it's work
also
besides that you expect her to be at
home and do all this housework and take
care of your [__] his twins right
and she's probably like [__] I would
like to go out and do something can you
watch the kids he's like no that's women
[__]
also by the way the laws say you can't
ever leave me oh wait they say you can
he's right he's right about that she
should be forced to stay yeah so we're
getting to that we're getting I'm having
too much fun with this already
and in the state of Texas that is
completely permitted
right it's been the most heartbreaking
experience
this was not
uh my choice my then wife decided that
she didn't want to be married anymore
and in the state of Texas that is
completely permitted
first of all yeah so woke asked liberal
[__] Texas has these insane lib laws
that says your wife can leave you if she
wants to that's so crazy that he thinks
that she's he's just like entitled to
her
that's what I wonder like what is the
alternative that she's forced to stay
with you forever like what that's what
they think I was reading up um on like
the conservative subreddits the reaction
to this because you know the vast
majority of the Internet is just making
fun of him for this what yeah good but I
was curious what like his fans thought
and yeah that what I saw consistently is
um you know marriage is a contract she
signed the contract you shouldn't be
able to just back oh no this is
like the bbtv argument you signed the
contract buddy right
yeah but she's a human being you want
her to be in a you want to imprison her
with you and she doesn't even like that
that's what I don't get she hates you
you want to keep her around that exactly
it's like why do you want to be with
somebody that has no interest in being
with you want to hang out it's going to
be too hard for him to find someone else
who will do it I guess because it's
embarrassing he probably just he's like
just go have sex with other people just
don't break up it's embarrassing
um no but like why does he say that like
where is that a thing in the United
States
um well I'm not sure what
all the specifics of marriage laws in
every state but I mean that's GPT that
used to be
um
like no fault divorce is a relatively
recent thing because back in back in the
good old days when when men ran
everything
um yeah it was it was a lot harder to
get divorced but you could just like I
I've never heard of people being forced
to stay in a marriage well I mean I I
think they would just make up any excuse
probably like emotional abuse or
uh whatever you just say anything right
or like in uh
lack of I don't know I don't know what
can you get divorced for
but uh apparently there's some State
less woke than Texas
where if if you suspect that your wife
is plotting to leave you
you can um
actually handcuff her to the radiator
and have a priest come and do an
exorcism until she agrees to stay with
you uh apparently yeah all 50 states in
the United States have some form of no
fault divorce law I'd like however the
specific requirements and processes for
obtaining a no-fault divorce may vary
from state to state so there you go I
like how he's just like blaming the
whole state of Texas for being too awoke
yeah
foreign
really caught me off guard
it's been the most heartbreaking
experience of my life what I consider it
to be where in the world is the woman a
captive to the man outside of like Isis
and like super conservative maybe like
Pakistan or some [__] like that his
dreams and his dreams
like this this is this is really
disturbing stuff
this is the world that they want to
build this is very disturbing stuff
um and he's got a gun on his desk too
which scares me a little bit
talking about his ex-wife you wanna know
something kind of crazy
go ahead uh so
the no fault divorce laws became calm in
the U.S starting in the late 60s uh
California was the first state to
introduce one so it is woke you're
welcome
uh but then it says uh you know over the
years the majority of States had some
form of no voice uh no fault divorce
legislation friend continued until all
50 states had it implemented with New
York being the last state to do so in
2010. that is interesting up to 2010
but I'm assuming there was ways to get
out it wasn't like you couldn't leave
right I think it just made the divorce
easier yes correct this idea that like
uh it's it's genuinely psychotic I mean
this man really wants to build like
Gilead
like dude you're a [__] loser bro
she left your ass and the only reason
you're sitting here is like I the only
reason she didn't stay is because I
couldn't physically force her to stay by
law that's what a loser you are you're
so unappealing
disgusting inside and out
and this woman has kids with you who I'm
sure she loves and wants the best for
them and yet she knows
that being separated from you because
you're so vile is what's best for her
and her kids
and that's who you are Stephen Crowder
you are just [__] rotten inside bro
vile Man by the way uh Ronald Reagan was
the one that uh
introduced that law in California so
well maybe it's not woke or just Reagan
is woke now dude
Reagan is woke now to be fair he is
quite woke by today's standards which is
nuts because he's a monster he'd be like
a mainstream Democrat it's crazy thank
you
uh Stephen Stephen
I know he dreaded this he wanted to
avoid this just because he he knew that
would make him look like such a
hypocrite and such a loser so [__]
stupid bro
such a little idiot
my deepest personal failure and just so
you know my opinions on parenting and
families have not changed I've always
believed that children need a mom and a
dad that divorce is horrible
and I still believe that children need a
mom and a dad and that divorce is
horrible probably should try to be a
better husband than idiot loser dumbass
small dick sorry that's not a bad thing
just get carried away sometimes
men with small dicks out there
we are brothers
we do what we we do what we can with
what we got
you know what I mean
but in today's legal system
my beliefs don't matter
again
foreign
what
like he he keeps bringing up
really harping on it isn't he
that that the law the state is against
him
because his wife can leave him by choice
I'm I genuinely don't understand what's
the alternative he wants her
to be forced
to live there
hating him
but she just has to stay there like what
is the what is that life you want
I don't get it yeah again it's just like
like even if it was self-respect man I
know she doesn't want you bro like why
do you want to be with this person that
is not wanting to be with she's just not
into you anymore yeah
that's what I just don't get even if it
was
legal for a woman to divorce or some
[__]
like to what end
in Texas divorces permitted when one
party wants it
period why do you keep saying that you
signed that contract to be a resident of
Texas dude yeah
what the [__] you signed that mortgage
sorry
you stuck stuck brother we should make a
GoFundMe to change that we should change
that change the law we gotta first
Steven Crowder
let's do a uh petition.org to force
Stephen Crowder's wife to go back to him
yeah share it
so for well over a year uh well over a
year in the best interest as well as
physical safety of my children we've
decided to keep this issue private and
to resolve it uh privately with the
appropriate attorneys what have you
legal jargon and all this one thing I
want to be really clear about is certain
True North here is that
my children are blameless again
very weird like of course they're
blameless
why would you even say that
because when parents get divorced you
know
as I understand a lot of times the kids
blame themselves
yeah so maybe he's saying that for the
sake of his kids yeah his kids are like
two young years old even watch his show
we tell them that but what what or being
like why would you even think that
these little [__] ruined everything
like what are you saying
I just want to say the one thing that we
all know to be true
is that these little [__]
did not cause a riff between me and my
wife
[Music]
my children it was 100 because of the
kids
[Laughter]
and it's not their fault it's just that
they were born and then she realized how
useless he is right and probably a bad
dad too
and then he probably gets so you know
some pathetic dads get uh they get
jealous of the attention the kids get
and they turn into little [__]
they go like uh
yo babe you're not spending any time
with me since we had the kids
that's Stephen
oh you think it was our fault maybe
after maybe we we hurt his heart you had
to get a heart problem since we I mean
damn cedared him yeah I watched Sam's uh
reaction to this yesterday and Sam did
bring up the possibility you know
he made it clear it wasn't intentional
but that he did not mean to [__] up his
whole life like this because that did
happen just a few months before right
when the divorce was happening the
timeline adds up that happened in our
episode with Crowder was in summer it
was in June of 2021 and six months later
Crowder was divorced we need to get
Crowder 20 button stat the same it was
in June
yo that sent him spiraling
that's awesome
you know but those kids would be better
off without him I'm sure of it
he is that [__] bile
children are blameless
completely without fault ah and so we
decided to resolve these issues
privately as it's in their best
interests uh both emotionally and
physically to do so
second mention of their physical safety
of his children I don't understand that
I don't know what the [__] he's
referring to with that
I think he he's trying to build some
kind of atmospheric
there's a theory that candy Owens puts
forth that I think has some credence
Credence is that the right word for that
yeah please don't say that word
but Credence climb water
that uh he he's trying to put up this
atmospheric
trying to get people to not probe into
his marriage and so he's trying to make
people think oh you're gonna put my
children's safety because some I the
theory is that something happened
and he's scared for people to find out
what did happen probably you know
you know the usual uh Motel math and gay
hooker uh prostitute kind of thing we
don't know that that's just that's the
regular I'll have the regular
that's that speculate that's the regular
oh [__] do you see that that was that
big yeah there's there's that was
Crowder's marriage
his wife was like I want a divorce
change my mind
they want to make that joke yet yeah uh
there's been a few but yeah in fact I
think we have that many money there was
one that said my wife wants to divorce
me change her mind yeah that's the one I
got in there I Can't Get Enough
yeah so I don't know what the thing
about like my kids lives are in danger
he's doing it's weird Chris you is
and this is something that I've kept
private
for likely far too long
um
many other people knew about this
behind the scenes
some not all but some of them in
positions of power
influence
Leverage
new of this
they also knew that the safety of my
children included keeping it private so
again what are we what are we talking
about this man's living like an episode
of 24
put the kids in the bunker the
terrorists know we're getting divorced
I don't know what you're talking about
how could they be in danger
familiar with the idea of extortion
then you know the feeling well
now this is a big claim right he's
saying he's been extorted with this
information
uh that he's getting the divorce which
doesn't seem like enough information to
extort someone on I mean you know it's
like okay tell people I'm getting
divorced he's
threats were so thinly veiled that I'm
frankly surprised you didn't all guess
immediately
okay so now crash cut to Miss Candy
Owens
my Queen Another vile vile hate
nasty person but somehow it comes out of
this looking way more sane than Crowder
actually I agree yeah I thought her
response to this I was like nodding
along with her the whole time I think
they're both I think she is Despicable
yeah no like she's so gnarly but the
fact that now they're just fighting
amongst each other and they're just
they're both just the worst
and I love that they're fighting each
other you know they say thick as thieves
and they're just scumbags and they uh
they just got caught in each other's
scumbag area
love it and I we saw this clip of candy
talking about
the Crowder situation when he exposed
daily wire for only offering him 50
million dollars a year or was it 50
million over three years 50 million over
some period of time I forget yes that
put that uh meager pathetic slave wages
slave wages I believe he called it yeah
uh she said this Ben has a lot going on
that's just the best way to say it he
has a lot going on and that should be
clear because people don't do stuff like
this if there's not a lot going on in
their lives I would like to implore my
audience and everybody that isn't paying
attention this situation not to condemn
him but to pray for him sometimes people
need that did not work by the way
unlike most times
we're praying is very effective and when
he said uh when he said that this was so
thinly veiled I'm surprised you all
didn't guess it
um I remember when we watched that
we did have a guest based off of that
and it wasn't that you were getting a
divorce dude I didn't know it seemed
like she was something worse
well I wouldn't say worseness I I
thought she was gonna out him that's way
worse I mean in their world this way
yeah that's way worse
um I agree but I will say that candy is
a demon for this like putting this out
there like hey dude I know you're
getting divorced and I'm gonna tell I
mean she was kind of doing that but it's
not you know but this was in the midst
of their whole crazy content I know but
everything this was demonic I felt even
for her to do this but they're both
scumbags yeah people need a scripture
you know Stephen purports to be a
Christian I am unsure at this moment if
it is my place to say more than that
it's definitely not it's 100 not your
place sure yeah
this man hasn't even talked about it
publicly
uh but you know what that's it that's
you know you started beef with literally
this most psycho pieces of [__] on the
internet what did you expect Crowder
yeah yeah Candace if you're thinking
about telling us I mean candy may as
well just tell us girl you girl you know
we are good we're best like that secret
we'll keep the secret mm-hmm
you know maybe if I feel in further
defense something should be said or
maybe if I feel that the public has a
right to understand certain
circumstances it's none of her business
to bring that up it's it's so corny but
again she's not extorting him I mean
she's just being a little catty she's
just being candy Owen she's she's a
nasty scumbag and
what do you expect Stephen making that
dumbass looking face
but now he's trying to turn what's he
doing here he's turning this divorce
announcement where he goes my kids are
in danger I don't want to turn this into
anything at all he's pivoting into the a
chapter two of daily wire beef right
where Candace Owen apparently is
extorting him which is a crime
I find that interesting
oh my children have a right to privacy
[Music]
now some other issues have been or I
should say uh
inferences have been more man if only
the leprechaun was there to back him up
I feel like this would be going smoother
for him
yeah well unfortunately the leprechaun
has a thing or two yeah so the
leprechaun as we call him Dave
so he got booted or no he left because
he was getting a shitty deal he did a
full tell all just
spewing all the tea like he hates
Stephen apparently and has
and he went on I mean he was being
somewhat diplomatic throughout it and
kept saying you know he likes Steven or
whatever but you can read between the
lines so he's like [__] this guy so
we're gonna do that one next so this is
like a whole human crowd of Bonanza Ela
says no comment
no no she's literally she just donated
ten dollars just ten bucks
no comment
or pernicious behind the scenes with
demands and threats to use this
information that they believe would be
so publicly embarrassing to me and my
wife in a difficult time that it could
be used knowingly putting my children In
Harm's Way so again I don't what he's
trying to say that candy
is trying to get his kids harmed
he seems to be implying that they knew
about his divorce and when all of the
beef was going on he because he mentions
behind the scenes I I feel like the
implication there is they said something
to him behind the scenes that if you
don't back off we're gonna expose your
divorce
that's what I think
the full well she was kind of saying
that candy yeah but the extortion would
have to come with some sort of thing not
public like the Veiled Threat or
whatever is one thing but for him to
claim like they were extorting me with
this information there would have to be
some sort of communication where it's
like if you don't shut the [__] up I
feel like expose your divorce I feel
like that did not happen
okay I mean I mean all these people suck
so much who's to say
candy addresses that specifically and
she makes it sound like of course that
didn't [__] happen this is good [__]
man I'm telling you I love it uh Ela uh
came back she said Olivia drink the
slave tea today
oh there we go
[Applause]
means the world and then she donated
again and said the first one I did the
Boomer thing sorry that's what I imagine
effing yeah thank you wow so generous my
beautiful wife wow
incredible isn't she the best folks my
wife ah it's so good to be married to my
wife I can't wait to go see my wife
later oh I'm sorry Stephen uh I didn't
mean to offend you uh I was a little
insensitive of me
yeah so uh
I am married
Temple not married
who's Alpha do the [__] math you [__]
bags you know what you know what the
problem is though it's definitely not me
nope and that's what Stephen said do
it's not me
it's divorce court it's the law
to those self-styled Christians
conservatives and allies
well not in my book got him now if you
find yourself I don't want to get into
details so this is going to likely be
the only time I have to address this or
want to address this if you're asking
yourself hey did ex person or did y
person know the answer is likely yes
which will be made alarmingly clear as
this process of discovery continues
so is that a a reference to a lawsuit
it's yeah I think that that is a lot a
threat of a lawsuit right there
it sounds almost like he's already filed
it the way he said it but I think candy
would have mentioned that yeah we I
remember Crowder has a history of
mentioning lawsuits that don't exist
remember he was suing YouTube as well
and uh that didn't happen never happened
there was no lawsuit there was like a
big announcement too remember he made
like a big to do about it like yeah as
of today we are suing YouTube and I
think they crowdfunded a bunch of money
on it too I think it's possible but I'm
pretty sure that I think I even asked
someone at YouTube was like Hey did this
ever happen or no well it's all public
info yeah we like search for it our
lawyers couldn't find anything yeah of
it happening yeah
uh and it also by the way makes me that
much more appreciative of those who did
know about this and in understanding the
best interests of my family my children
kept their word and used discretion uh I
can't thank you enough sincerely I
appreciate it won't forget it it was
just her I mean just candy
you kind of didn't she didn't even say
it she's just gonna you know
again I I
didn't my mind didn't go to divorce no
nope with that video nope we all thought
you were just gay dude right like
everybody just thought that
yeah
although one might lead to the other
we'll see it's it's pretty simple I
loved a woman so much that I married her
a woman who despite all of this I still
love as the mother of my children
and she wanted something else for her
life
that's not my choice
she simply wanted out and the law says
that that's how it works again do not
sound do you not understand how
psychotic you sound right now I really
don't my wife wanted out
and so who am I to force someone to stay
in a relationship with me no the law in
woke Texas says she can leave me
it's uh it's unreal in fact so now of
course look I get it there are multiple
sides to every story but one thing that
is undeniable uh in this case is that
it's no one's fault but my own
in that I picked wrong and that
that's disgusting no maybe you just
didn't treat her well enough yeah I
thought I was picking a woman who would
sit down and shut up and be in the
kitchen and take care of the kids turns
out I picked a [__] [__] yeah
oh what you want to divorce well did you
check did you check the state law to see
if that's even legal
wait it is in all 50 states since 1970.
[__] that's true yeah I think if he's
ever to get married again he's going to
need to start
building some kind of dungeon
underground or something to restrain her
in case divorce is ever brought up
or possibly just moving to uh Isis yeah
I was gonna say Saudi Arabia Saudi
Arabia could suit your needs they don't
have as many rights there so that might
that might align with your beliefs
where's Isis these days
uh uh they are um yeah I don't know Al
Qaeda probably a taliban's probably down
with that right they're everywhere
they're everywhere Google some Isis
videos there's one right in front of me
his name's Stephen Crowder
what's the difference
I mean at the end of the day it's just
fomo yeah that's certainly on both of my
children getting mad ice is fomo right
now ice is all about the phone
[Laughter]
and I will say that what's in the best
interest of my children um is not
internet drama speculation
certainly not blatant or veiled
shakedowns or dragging their father or
mother and I can't be clear on enough or
their mother through the mud
and I only have nice things to say about
your wife
I know anything about her but I know she
makes she you know I'm making the right
choice she's good on this one she's good
on the right side of History
that's right girl
dude I hope she goes and starts dating
like a hardcore lib you know what I mean
be awesome she finds a new love someone
who's willing to go down on her you know
this new guy doesn't think vaginas are
icky and gross exactly
I bet this her new boyfriend won't even
make her put a bag over her head and
talk in a low voice right
they can get rid of the sheep with the
whole cheat with the hole yeah you don't
need that that's gonna make a big
difference for her love life
by the way here's Ila donating to uh the
podcast this is basically what's
happening here thank you
[Applause]
there needs to be a third person there
in between that's taking a little 30 tax
foreign
too what does that mean
you're right
you know what I mean
oh because they take a cut as well right
right yeah I don't even allow that
I think I mean they didn't for a while I
think it I think you can donate from own
iPhone now I think they yeah
I'm looking into it yeah I'm not exactly
sure
your member right
yeah she's probably on the computer
you know yeah
moving on
I'm no longer going to pacify capitulate
or sidestep because I love them a whole
lot more than I love you and I will
continue to do whatever is necessary to
protect my children
discussing a divorce any further on
social media or on this show or in any
public space it's not what's best for
them yeah but so that's why then why did
you in your video
Levy this attack against candy Owens who
is one of the most
volatile people on the internet like of
course she gonna come back and cause a
big drama
[Music]
so like if that's true then why did you
do this with candy friends with candy
remember that show
what strangers oh you're thinking
Strangers With Candy that's one of my
favorite shows of all time Rangers with
candy that's that's me and her I hate
this candy
stop we look we love strangers of candy
you don't like candy Ian
yeah
why are you showing Zach go on do
something respond
oh I don't know what you're talking
about he's turning around on you go on
pick one
F tier easy okay there you go I donated
it worked fine all right and and okay
interesting and did it charge you more
than usual no it's okay or they made an
arrangement with them yeah we're not
apples just taking an extra cut that's
all that means a secret cut
that's my guess but then what the [__]
then you get like two dollars yep from a
five dollar donation pretty sure that's
how it works
wow that's crazy that can't be true
that no I'm almost certain that that's
true Apple any app that you downloaded
through the Apple App Store they get a
cut that's part of the if you want your
if you want to be on their App Store you
gotta play by their rules but I but I do
think it's a chance that Google
negotiated something with them because
it wasn't on the iPhone for a long time
and YouTube Google has that cloud I feel
like I guess Google is probably one of
the few that can uh
because usually when you buy stuff from
Apple I've noticed it's more expensive
to cover
their fee
right yeah maybe maybe they did arrange
something that's just too depressing to
think about otherwise okay if it makes
you happy it says the uh however the fee
doesn't apply to free apps usually 30
for in-app purchases
but uh free for the fee doesn't apply
free apps oh
interesting that is that doesn't make
any sense yeah I know
because they did it for a camera right
they take 30 from Championship right
exactly yeah so it's pretty awesome but
is cameo a free yeah I can that's right
yeah I mean but there's there's really
okay whatever I don't care let's watch
this feeling this through the proper
legal Avenues and channels available as
a matter of record in which I have more
than full confidence
so I'd ask that you understand the need
for and uh respect our privacy and
what is obviously a pretty tough time
and I hope that none of this has to go
any further than that well then why did
you [__] threaten Candace Owens the
psychoist person on the internet dummy
like it was so stupid just move on dude
but okay he wanted to go there
I feel terrible for her man he's going
through so much that's tough here's a
more accurate uh update to this image
taking their little tax yeah tax gnomes
I love that
all right so moving on now right after
Stevie boy drops this he goes to Twitter
and he posed
a video of he says this is the
straightest thing I've seen all day and
he posts
to I think gay dudes
having a lovey-dovey moment I think one
is trans actually okay
and so I guess this is what's on his
mind
now that he's single I don't know what
the point was here I don't get it does
anybody have any thoughts on this and he
says this is the straightest thing I've
seen all day does that include when you
looked in the mirror in the morning
because you gay boy
that mean yes he's giving each other our
home our hormones I think they're both
trans okay giving each other our
hormones okay okay I see I didn't know
that so they're trans
so okay great they're bonding they're
having uh Stephen just wants people to
bully these these uh which is like yeah
at least they're together look at how
happy they are together more than
anything you have Stephen yeah that's
why he's upset exactly 100
why he's like Why didn't mine work but
that works right this is so stupid maybe
because they're nice to each other right
oh wait wait what's this oh I didn't see
his reaction part play it
I'm serious
what's beautiful about injecting your
spouse with a hormone that's far into
their body what does it matter dude
that all the time
hey what's beautiful about a single
loser ass divorced [__] [__] ass
closeted
freaking demon what's what's cute about
that
whatever is being injected if they're a
man in his estrogen cancer it's bad if
they're a woman and it's testosterone
who knows possibly cancer definitely
some right are you a doctor correct me
if I'm wrong there was a girl that
became a guy and a guy that became a
girl I can't correct you because
they're very funny over there I'm louder
with Crowder I don't know yeah nobody
does any guy so right as he's announced
his divorce and we all speculated it was
because he was closeted the the
blackmail he goes straight to Twitter to
be like nope I I Pro no dudes I hate gay
people gay and trans people are icky and
gross
are you a compens overcompensating much
uh Stevie boy
yes baby uh let's see the divorce
proceedings started in December 2021
Candace Owen uh has responded to Steve
and of course she would right I mean how
could she not familiar and here it is
um
here with the idea of extortion
then you know the feeling well
uh now some of these
threats
were so thinly veiled that I'm frankly
surprised you didn't all guess
immediately things should be said or
maybe if I feel that the public has a
right to understand certain
circumstances
[Music]
oh my children have a right to privacy
he even sent me a retrospectively very
flirty message thereafter on Instagram
about how nice I looked on Election
night even though I didn't respond to it
dropped those receipts girl please do
that let me know more I need those DMS
now we gotta get her in here
tea time
that'd be the funniest friend of the
show ever to me
yeah maybe we could win her over don't
think that's happening
maybe I could pay whatever daily wires
paying her maybe I can double it and
give her a show over here
yeah right new member of the cruise
she's probably making like 10 million
dollars a year yeah nobody watches her
show either
yeah I can't afford that fortunately
Crowders Instagram account and I look to
see and it turned out that she didn't
follow Stephen Crowder and that Stephen
Crowder didn't follow her
he didn't follow anybody in her family
and she wasn't following any so I'm
sorry that is me
I do that [__] all the time
so she's making she's making a valid
point she says look I didn't know you're
divorce you just you guys stop following
each other on Instagram I mean you know
what does that mean you know everything
although she's she's probably lying she
do
she was talking so confidently about it
that's how people learn that people
breakups
they check and then they're given an
answer there it is yeah well
the clues were out there Stevie boy is
the point okay you're not special nobody
cares about your pasty single ass loser
idiot
anybody in his family that was my aha
moment clearly there was some sort of a
separation now I will not take that
lightly okay I am not Hillary Crowder I
am not anybody in his family I am not
going to take somebody going onto his
platform and alleging that I either
harassed threatened or did anything that
would put his children at risk that is
very serious stuff that he is saying I
mean she's not wrong this is where what
I was saying I was like nodding along
with this clip was like what like she is
not wrong at all this man straight up
implied that she wanted to hurt I mean
in a way hurt his kids like like
physically
physical safety three times
and so what I did this morning after
this clip was sent to me is I contacted
a defamation lawyer and I am sending
someone's daughter a cease and desist
and I'm going to demand a full-throated
retraction to the idea that Candace
Owens threatened him or extorted him
enough it seems to me yeah I mean
minus if he just has an email from her
saying if you don't do this then this
there's no way she'd like actually
extorted him
I don't think that right what she said
right even that you really for whatever
reason want to insert me into this
narrative something about I feel like if
he had that he would have shared that of
course because he's already we know that
he records his phone calls and we know
that he's willing to leak private
conversations if you had that why
wouldn't you share that he doesn't have
it because now the information's out so
there's nothing to lose right like you
are telling the world that you're
getting divorced so if you have evidence
of somebody trying to Blackmail you they
no longer have the leverage over you why
not to share that and we know that he
would so I think it's [__] yeah it's
seems to me Stephen that you really for
whatever reason want to insert me into
this narrative like there is just
something about me that you are hyper
focused on and so I want to help you a
bit and really I want to help your wife
because you essentially just used your
platform millions of people have access
to your platform she doesn't have the
same to insult her you picked the wrong
woman okay girl pop off candy I Am So
based right now okay girl
snapping for you girl we love her now
love her now
we like her we like her okay so here's
what I would like to do I would like to
invite Hillary Crowder onto my platform
it's funny let me get my popcorn and
she's obviously not going to take the
opportunity but it is a funny job all
right then I hope she does there's no
way I know I don't think there is a way
that would be way too good to be true
man
but it is very funny
she's really good at getting under
people's skin I mean daily wire daily
wire could be like we'll pay for your
divorce attorney that's true they have a
crazy people on our show like I'm sure
they gladly do that you know what
that's fire
that's a good idea he just used his to
insult her to say that he picked the
wrong woman I find that to be really
despicable good for you Hillary Crowder
if you are watching you are more than
welcome to come on my show and to talk
about what's actually going on love her
for that please accept the invitation
please but yeah I mean Candy's not wrong
on this one
that was she's right I mean there was no
need for you to bring her up in your
video there really wasn't like just you
know this information came out
and so he felt the need to address it I
guess on the show frankly he could have
just put out a statement or something
that I'm you know unfortunately my wife
and I are being divorced it's not my
choice yada yada you know what I mean
but he decided to do it on video and
then yeah just like like she said just
for some reason broke her into the
conversation
it's like wasn't needed but and then at
the same time being like I don't want to
talk about this I just wanted to go away
in the interest of my kids and you're
doing some of these obviously going to
provoke
further drama
you know what I'm saying
uh there's some dominoes I want to read
Midas Touch just as Midas Touch oh AI
music videos are getting insane search
DSL Ready Set Go
okay
thank you uh jayate
says can I please get a shout out for my
boyfriend Ben we love Ben Benny I'm in
your walls Ben it's me
Nick Clark says much like Ethan stealing
hairlines David is stealing windows to
the soul interesting
Marilyn Williams can I get a shot for my
22nd birthday
Carolyn Williams I'm 22. [__] you [__]
you
mm-hmm
sorry I just want to acknowledge
everybody
Nick Clark his liberal twin Hassan [__]
dude
I've seen photoshops where they look
pretty similar I hate to say it but they
look a little I mean obviously Hassan's
way more handsome
but because Crowders there's a little
bit of like a Mirror Universe thing
going on there though there was one of
Mia's Temple and uh it's so funny
uh
uh J J Audi says can I get a shout out
for Ben shat a
Shakti
Shakti and Henry yes you can
you sure can
did I already do the shout out by
reading it or do I need to like uh Ben
Shakti and Henry Ben Shock 3 Henry it's
me Ben Shock 3 Henry
okay that's it thank you guys sorry if I
missed your donation I
been captivated
oh yeah I don't know if I showed this in
it is quite [__] disturbing but take
it for what it is
Bizarro
universe
it's powerful this is a powerful image
it really is it is quite unsettling I
will say
I hate this at like I feel like a
different conservative grifter is a
better fit for you like I know you're
you know you're known for the beanie but
if anybody I'm the bald guy with the
beanie like I'm Tim Poole in this
situation right
I'll let you be too boy I don't want
that I don't want that comparison I just
I wonder if there's another one out
there that's a better one some some
curly conservative uh grifter that
matches up with your your whole vibe hmm
Jim Brewer oh God
anyway funny stuff moving on there's a
lot more to get to actually there's all
kinds of little wrinkles in here
uh here's a bunch of memes of people
dunking on crowder
all of them just fantastic
pentagon hexagon octagon my wife is gone
and again his wife left him
right which is pathetic and sad my wife
went out for pizza without me even worse
man
she went for pizza and never came back
uh quartering my wife is leaving me
change her mind please I'm begging you
this man was out here arguing with
college students while his wife was like
out the door she was like I [__]
can't stand this dude I need a divorce
oh no people are saying you're oh no I
go ahead you can say consensus on who
your mirror universe is okay go ahead
it's Jeremy
it's not Jeremy everyone's saying
quartering there's a lot of quartering
in the chat that's that's I'm so sorry
I'm not happy about being Temple I'd
rather be Temple but I'm just trying to
be real about it right I would rather be
Temple than court or anybody but Jeremy
Jeremy's a [__]
that man shits and pisses on the floor
of his own house I like his his heart on
the inside inside inside yeah he's
ordering is a little IQ inbred loser I
need to believe that
that's how I feel about him
say that again
look I'm 40. I'm tired I'm sweaty I'm
fat I do feel that I feel cornering is a
low IQ inbred loser that was the title
of our highlights that I guess he had a
problem with for some reason I don't
know why listen listen up liberals my
wife left me
oh [__] that's funny uh-oh uh oh
that's good
um
here is now
here is a clip of every time Crowder has
dressed up in drag over the past two
years when this divorce proceeding has
been happening
let's see
here he is let's see
uh let's count the number of times I
just don't
I just don't Mr Hyde rearing is ugly
bisexual head that was that was a short
phase
um
whoa milkers oh that's like a lot of
times
good
yeah as this video went on I
it's kind of shocking hello many times
it is which is like it's fine it can be
fun to do that's my life we've done it
on the show you've dressed in drag on
the show it's not a problem not but like
this many times for someone who is yeah
expressly transphobic yes
is a little bit and like he is like way
in character
he's method he's method is [__] bro I
think this is the first time he's not in
character
so that's a whole compilation of Steven
and drag
everyone I see people saying he looks so
happy there he did that's what I'm
saying
he does there was sincere happiness
ordering highlight titles I don't know
why Jeremy has a problem with these I
like titles the quartering one
two peas in his basement three as a
crotch right you get that crotch rot and
then this is the one that he uh really
hated the quartering is a low IQ inbred
loser
inbred I don't see what's wrong with
that right on the highlights channel is
like a Haven for haters oh [__] we have
so much fun with those titles though
don't we yeah
that's right
that is fun
oh my god oh we have a Saudi found who
says big fan but the Saudi slander is
always so unoriginal and inaccurate to
the country's progress Saudi women
religiously and legally have more rights
just saying
okay sure more Progressive than uh
Crowder sure I I gotta say I do get
messages every time from Saudi fans like
how dare you like I don't [__] know
I'm not in the Discord hold up hold on
hold on hold on
listen I'm not I'm not saying anything
about our D our lovely Saudi uh fans and
we do have some
I remember we had a caller from Saudi
Arabia a while ago that was real
interesting but
can women get a divorce
in Saudi
Arabia
let's ask chat gbt who's more
Progressive
okay it says yes women in Saudi Arabia
can get a divorce however the process
can be more difficult for women compared
to men
because of Islamic law
there are a few ways a woman can
initiate a divorce Kula there's a form
of divorce initiated by the wife where
she returns her dowry
uh uh
talak a tough tough feed
and some marriage contracts a husband
May delegate his right to initiate
divorce to his wife allowing her to end
the marriage okay good terms they
negotiated a favorable terms fosk this
is a Judicial divorce granted by the
court due to specific circumstances such
as husbands impotence yo
that's crazy
desertion or cruelty
the wife must provide evidence so well
you got to take a pic of his flaccid
dick
talak a husband can unilaterally divorce
his wife by pronouncing talek three
times you just say three times talic
Talent
however husband divorces his wife this
way she can also file for a Judicial
divorce to seek her rights okay so it
sounds like you know
more liberal than Crowder's uh
Crowder's dream
situation
here's another you guys want to see more
Crowder or quartering titles the
quartering's perverted search history
exposed I mean that's just very
technical
that one's not even that mean why do you
care
no I'm just interested in you Jeremy I
find you interesting
um
I'm not long for this planet
yeah there it is nah bro I don't like
Jeremy either so moving on
um
here's some old tweets
of Stevens that are coming back to haunt
him
since he is now a divorced dad here he
is in 2002 2022
this is during his divorce drama
seems to be a direct comment on his wife
women are doing less work at home
they're unhappier divorce rates are
skyrocketing and men don't want to marry
them great job feminism
somehow it's just not his fault is it
right it was your wife who didn't want
to be married to you anymore because
yeah because she has more time on her
hands because she's doing less work at
home and so she has more time she thinks
that she's entitled to her own happiness
wow what a freak freak ass and she votes
no great job feminism I'm sure Crowder
blames feminism for his wife leaving him
bro
this is why you're this is why your wife
left you brother
this right here
uh there's more of course
that's it
ranting about no fault divorces here he
is again
this is last year around the same time
yes it's tragic Stephen Crowder with Roe
overturned the right to same-sex
marriage should be next he says yeah but
to regulate same-sex marriage you know
why keep go ahead with the sad music I
think it's very fitting
because states have different divorce
laws
State issue oh it's no fault divorce
which by the way means that in many of
these states a woman cheats on you she
leaves she takes half
yeah that's how I mean yeah I mean it
sucks that she cheated on you Steven but
it's still her life
you guys got married it's like you
complain about the contract this is the
contract you guys are made you're
together
she's entitled to that if she's at home
taking care of your [__] kids without
your
absent badass
dead ass bad ass deadbeat ass
she gets half bro what do you want her
you're the mother of your kids to go
starve
scumbag
Dad let's focus on the fact she cheated
on you that's bad enough the fact that
she gets half
kinda makes sense to me Stephen
he goes I don't want her to work but
also she's not entitled to have which
way do you want it dude you can't have
it both ways
yeah it's sad it is tragic yeah by the
way I think that state should have the
right to regulate same-sex marriage you
know why because states have different
divorce laws
State issue oh it's no fault divorce
which by the way means that in many of
these states a woman cheats on you she
leaves she takes half I think he I think
his wife I think uh
just a little longer no because this was
right when divorce was happening
so it's not no fault no it's the fault
of the man
the money is not about whose fault it is
it's just fair
[Music]
you know what I mean
that's just the way it is brother
look you can argue until you're blue in
the face even the women who separate
yourself from feminist well she is
entitled to forty percent forty percent
of young men don't want to get married
thins out the hurt a little bit what do
you want
do you want to have do you want to be
able to get married
or do you want to be living hussy for
the rest of your life there's gonna have
to be a compromise there need to be
changes to to marital laws
the duty is so crazy such a freak his
argument is I need you to stay at home
and work but if we get divorced you get
nothing
then why the [__] should she be at home
raising the kids she should be out
getting her own job then and living her
own life
Patty's so pathetic
why would she leave him I just don't get
it I don't even talk about same-sex
marriage talking about divorce laws
talking about alimony laws talking about
child support laws men now don't want to
get married it's a raw deal for a lot of
them and I'm not on board with the the
men's rights activists who believe that
they shouldn't be held accountable for
any certainly not on board with the
pickup culture the idea of one night
stands not at all but I am saying that
there does need to be a give and take to
all legal contracts that's not the case
in many of these no-fault divorce States
so he is talking about his own divorce
it's tragic I mean it's really Breaking
My Heart
[Music]
wife probably found Brad the bull uh one
night and
thanks for taking care of her and the
stable
and she he took her for the ride of her
life
[Music]
somebody said she's getting louder
without Crowder right oh that's such a
good one
shout out ye boy for that one it it's
hard to interpret this uh monologue any
other way
again June 24th to 2022 this was during
the after he said the divorce stuff
started it was in June
that's what I said yeah I don't know why
it's outlandish to say well this state
can make it no fault and this state can
say that if you cheat you forfeit your
right to the division of property
and States can't say by the way these
are the qualifications for marriage
namely a man and a woman I I don't know
again legally you may not like it but it
seems to me that it should be a state
issue
I want the state as uninvolved in
marriage as possible yes so then your
fault okay so the state shouldn't be
involved yet at the same time the state
should compel my wife to Stay With Me
yeah
yeah it's a little weird right if the
state's not involved then she could just
leave at any time
but then he's saying well
if she leaves me then she should be
forced to stay with me because she would
be financially destitute without me
which which was a lot of reason why
women stayed in these horrific
relationships back in the day
because they had no Financial Freedom so
that this is what Stephen wants
that makes sense to me
or sure you can leave
but what are you gonna do you're gonna
be homeless you know what I mean I'm not
gonna give you a penny
no Stephen
[Music]
Stevie Stevie Stevie thanks for taking
care of her bro
as a Christian it's a covenant between
you
your wife or your husband and God
it didn't say and thou shalt go to the
courthouse and give half
Thou shalt Thou shalt have joint Ally
bank accounts you know what I mean I
just it ends up unfortunately it's
destroyed the institution of marriage
for young Christian men how many I mean
you can do that right like you don't
have to get legally married you could
just go to church and tie the knot like
a religious wedding and yeah and
cohabitate absolutely that's well there
there's two marriage decisions right
there's religious and then there's
there's a state right like a civil yeah
civil recognition
but unfortunately for Stephen Crowder
even living together
uh there's a common law marriage where
because so people like Stephen Crowder
can't [__] right Roy yeah Is Us his
you know significant other's life
and hold them hostage essentially in a
horrible marriage which is what he has
said he wants to do
that's awesome man chats do we get how
many emails do we get in this there's
there hasn't been a show that's been
more Pro institutional marriage than
this program and how many and yet here I
am Christian going like yeah you know I
really but I'm really afraid to do this
because I live in a state where even if
she cheats on me and she leaves I have
to pay half and I have to pay alimony
and we go like why are you so worried
about her cheating on you
like
why are you so insecure
[Music]
you know
if marriage is so beautiful and holy
just just trust the process brother
it's a raw deal where I'm almost at the
point of quantificating
church is a covenant that's it for the
state at that point
because you guys should be together
because you make a covenant before God
which should be stronger than the state
it shouldn't be about property and tax
benefits unfortunately I understand why
it is
because we wanted to create a nuclear
family as a building block for society
here but I don't understand you know
people act as though it's this travesty
if states can determine all kinds of
marital laws why can't states determine
they can determine what qualifies for a
marriage in many other facets they can
say well you can't marry someone why
because you're already married so you
can't marry a second one he said well
okay that's fine they can say hey well
you can't you can't take half why
because you cheated so you can't you
don't get to divide half of this that's
nothing to do with the half she cheated
on him bro he's obsessed with this they
cheated she cheated this girl cheated
she wants that
sounds like she got some strange dick
bro
and it sounds like he was able to get
hard
it's even probably [__] eats dialysis
for breakfast or what is it called
Cialis it's like a Viagra thing ocos
yeah oh oh oh yeah
wear this wig and talk in a deep voice
baby
it's my birthday
[Music]
at this point okay but then another
state says I don't care that she cheated
she she can take half or he can take
half if she's the primary earner
well you can't get married why because
you both have dicks
what a loser Jesus Christ unhappy
marriages are worse for children than
happy separated co-parents says Evie 100
percent
you know at a certain point as bad as
divorce is
it's at a certain point it's going to be
better for the kids to not be around two
people that hate each other as the model
of love for them to look up to that's
like lifelong trauma
uh here
keeps going on about it only that on the
day he tweeted this uh Crowder also
tweeted
another thing on Twitter this is from
again
September 8 2022 I just wish women
understood how much men loved them and
want this is like weird nice guy School
shooters yeah for real I just wish women
understood how much men loved them and
want them to be the woman they were
designed to be
dude you're so [__] divorced [__]
I'm gonna need to start being the woman
I was designed to yeah I don't think
that I'm fulfilling that prophecy yet
again this is one day this is while the
divorce is happening
and he's wondering how could she believe
me
what was she designed to be like a [__]
hole I mean like genuinely what was a
woman designed to be that implies that
she has some function or purpose
by design it was designed to not leave
him
right just to be a [__] hole I mean I I
know that's very vulgar but like what's
the biological design of women in
Crowder's mind I'm guessing he means to
obey yeah
[Music]
uh you know clean the house cook the
meals raise the kids never opposed
have your own thoughts let me borrow
your clothes sometimes and try them on
don't don't don't tell on me when you
find me in your aunt panties
put on little plays together
make a little movie
we go to the gay club together just
because I like that the guys aren't
hitting on you makes me feel interested
right
great song selections too right great
songs to dance cocktails are insane Club
yeah they're so good there
I hate those gays but man they make a
mean cocktail
did I say [__] hmm
yeah this man is psychotic
ah Stevie
this is why like white
Christian
nationalists think that they're being
like uh
think that they're like the
being counter uh
they think they're down and out they're
like they're like yo what happened to
this great world where nobody could [__]
with us
what a [__] nightmare you're saying
that I can be a total psycho scumbag
piece of [__] and my wife can actually
leave me like there's consequences
dude the system is rigged against me
no
the state needs to change that
right
so sad it's so tragic uh he put out
another video about no fault divorce
he's obviously taught he's talked about
this he's on the knives
and these are all recent here's a clip
from September 7th 2022. it's not your
fault same day as that last tweet
mystically
it is his fault Robin
don't tell him it's not his fault it is
his fault it's fault
incredible that women
they spend far the awful old days as
they show in that that trailer women
spend less time on household chores now
it's Fallen by 44 since 1976. what a
tragedy hey girl like if that if you're
bothered by that you [__] lost that
life oh my God you've lost their life
your fault it's your fault thank you
thank you Robin
good the evil oppression of men asking
you to help clean a house which is up
they probably because they're all
[__] got jobs bro it's nice that
you're like a billionaire based on just
being racist
women have jobs dude
also yours and he likes likely pays for
hey good you don't have to clean thanks
Roomba oh my God he's so angry oh man
what the [__] is his
taking the women's job
of sweeping the floor of my house we
must we must abolish Roomba
a Roomba is like a [__] Terminator
for him the state needs to do something
about those roombas what's next the
roomba's gonna [__] my wife too
laughs
oh he's so exposing himself in all these
videos but here's the thing as
ores and duties have fallen down because
that's what oppresses women we have
study after study after study here's one
by the American economic Association
showing that women are more unhappy than
ever here's a quote the lives of women
in the United States have improved over
the past 35 years by many objective
measures yet we show that measures of
subjective well-being indicate that
women's happiness has declined both
absolutely here's the thing both
absolutely and relative to men you know
what else we have now is a byproduct of
feminine men won't get married
given an entire generation of men I find
this is a little bit dubious this stat
he recited
Paradox of declining female happiness
all sources available in description
the lives of women in the United States
have improved over the last 35 years
by many objective measures yet we show
that measures of subjective well-being
indicate that woman's happiness has
declined is it possible that all have
declined all she says relative to men
this decline in relative well-being is
found across various data sets measures
of subjective well-being demographic
groups and industrial countries relative
decline in female happiness have eroded
a gender gap in happiness in which women
in the 1970s reported higher subjective
well-being than men did
these declines have continued
and a new gender gap is emerging one
with higher subjective well-being for
men
I'd like to check this the
veracity of those claims
you know
did you ask chat gbt yet
if Stephen Crowder is citing a statistic
it's like a 99.9 percent chance that
he's misinterpreted I'm Prager you yeah
yeah so I mean maybe
adult incest
or relative to men you know what else we
have now is a byproduct of something men
won't get married
you have an entire jet men are not
marrying because uh for many men the
reward for getting married are far less
than they used to be
well the cost and dangers of it are far
higher that sounds like extremely biased
in the way it was written
what do you mean less rewarding
millions of men no longer want to get
married and you can thank the government
for that yeah I wonder gee I wonder who
wrote this article
your fault
generate generation of men who are
refusing to get married last number I
heard I don't I'm going by wrote I
believe was 30 something percent it was
nearing 40 something percent and women
say I don't care I don't need a man till
they realize they're hitting that age
where that window is closing biology is
real despite what Cosmo tells you so
women are doing less work at home
they're doing less work at home they're
getting more Angry they're more unhappy
divorce rates are skyrocketing and men
don't want to marry you also because of
feminists thank you for doing your part
for that Stephen
you're doing your report
I love that it's my fave right now
um wow how I can't imagine the
I can't imagine
why she left him man
weird
can't imagine it fall
tracking down clips of Stephen oh is
this this guy's been doing all of God's
work
tracking down clips of Stephen talking
about divorce on the show
we've seen all these uh I included all
the good ones in the dock but I mean
honestly I we get we get the idea uh
well let's one more that women
they spend far the awful old days as
they show in that that trailer women
spend less time on household chores now
it's Fallen by 44 since 1976. okay dude
yeah
just [__] wash the dishes bro it's
not that serious
uh so that's kind of what's going on
there but then the Jew the gossip
continues uh his ex leprechaun Dave
landu who we've made fun of uh Dave is
not funny
or interesting so I'm not surprised that
they fired him yeah
I'm sorry Dave he apparently was
considered you know the peak of comedy
on the show though so it it seems like
it was a loss because the the Crowder
fans uh have been missing him although
they might turn on him now now that he's
spilled all the beans sorry Dave so you
guys probably recognize him he was just
sitting there like his little sidekick I
don't know who's the one uh you will
recall when when uh when Sam Cedar
showed up he scurried across the frame
he's the one that they uh switched to so
Crowder could hide right apparently he's
so funny he can handle
you can handle it all I'd like to see
some of his sets I know this guy is just
a horrible comedian bro I know it it has
to be true
let me see
not even all the time here's a trailer
for his one hour special
let's see
[Music]
oh [__] is it gonna get clean yeah I
think it is this is definitely not worth
I I I want to see a clip I like that
little synth lick though that's pretty
pretty
I want to see a clip of this man's
comedy
uh but yeah I mean he's a piece of [__]
I don't like him at all but uh he got
fired or left and now he's doing all the
gossip rounds and I love it
because he was with Crowder for a long
time right
at least two years because that's when
we Sam cedared him he was there then yo
five years ago this guy had three
million views on his uh special with
Comedy Central so he was kind of a
kind of popping he went to Crowder for
his career to die yo he had a mohawk
what the [__] all right is this Gonna
Get Us claims God damn I hate what I'm
saying let's just let me catch one joke
Dave Landau comedy episode this is going
to be the most money if he gets the
claim on this give me the most money
he's made in decades
open as a warning yeah that's because
you're [__] with their business
you know what people want to buy way
more than fruits and vegetables crack
nobody's ever sucked dick for an orange
that's never happened
all right I don't want to get claimed
yeah
but anyway he's so he so here's some
clips he starts by saying
um now he left when they moved to the uh
Rumble and nobody knew what happened or
why
and uh the gossip's coming out for some
reason he first of all says he wasn't
allowed to say come I think it made
Stephen hard to imagine a men's a man's
semen out in the come just blasting
through the air towards his
Maybe
come oh I'm sorry I was watching some of
his stand-up I was trying to find
something what is it oh nothing you're
good gum here it is I had been more
censored as things went on where I
couldn't for example say the word come
okay uh like ejaculate I forgot when I
made the joke that was offensive or
whatever it was you could only eat it
you couldn't say it's gonna go in your
mouth
not come out of here right now I could
eat it with a spoon or I could say yummy
yum yums when referring to it but I
could never actually say I could eat it
with a fork I could eat it on a ship
that's very interesting no cummies no
gummies
how come he's allowed hmm
I thought he was against censorship
talking about Stephen installing a Dave
don't talk button I need one of those
for you guys yeah this man
the image you get from him is a man who
is so so
deeply dysfunctionally insecure
he installed a button when he starts
talking too much he hits the button and
he's got to shut up
yeah he well he I'll let him explain
here it is it became a little weird
because the light was put in where it
was his rant button
and it was basically a Dave don't talk
button wait so there's literally a light
bulb what color was the light bulb there
was four lights in a row
serious and it when it was hit I wasn't
supposed to talk and they said what was
it like a regular colored light bulb I'm
sorry but this is [__] tea this is
hilarious you're so insecure it's
insecurity alpha or not I don't know it
seems kind of better to me
shut up dude
you're talking too much
stop it
like fish when the lights are on you
have to shh
the rule said so
uh it was like a a yellow uh pretty
bright yellow like a you know like yield
so it's like off camera but in your eyes
the eyesight yes and he did it when
pressing the button or was there a
producer pressing the button he would
press it so like router had a button at
his desk
that's pretty incredible man and that's
that's like that's like some pretty
serious uh engineering I would say right
Dan
I mean yeah get a button right here I
haven't seen that kind of engineering
since Matt Lauer so yeah yeah exactly
Jesus yeah I gotta I'd be like yo I need
a button on my desk
that lights up a big ass light like why
would you even want to um
why would you even want to manage that
while you're doing a show
he would just get so pissed that this
guy was trying to be funny or
entertaining he had to hit the buttons
like he had a button under his desk or
the table and when it's Steven's turn to
talk and Dave needs to shut the f up he
presses this button yes how do I get
this to happen because frankly we're 13
minutes in and you already have my last
nerve
there is like 15 minutes of content in
this interview and the rest of it is
them riffing so you're gonna see a lot
of that
should I keep watching from this point I
mean
there's a button you get the idea
that's embarrassing boy
uh weird detail that when he pushed back
about it he was told it was always there
wait I want to see that
Dave started gaslighting it became a
little weird because the light was put
in where it was his rant button was it
like a regular colored light bulb was it
like red uh it was like a uh and when
it's Steven's turn to talk and Dave
needs to shut the f up he presses this
button yes how do I get this to happen
because frankly we're 13 minutes in and
you're already on my last nerve
this is with Michael now aren't you
hitting it now
oh that's that's just zoom doing it
um yeah he uh yeah he um he had that
well and then he I was told he's like
well that was always there and I'm like
no I would have noticed the the light
inventory he's always there folks you
know how expressvpn Okay slick little ad
uh it was always my shut up Dave button
was always there
pretty wild thing to lie about Corey has
a new button uh suggestion for a new
button for Crowder a button to make his
wife's stay right yeah
that's like the Matt Lauer button
Virginia says I married my high school
sweetheart after 18 years and I could
not be happier suck it Crowder
Christopher just donated five dollars
and said doesn't the AC crew all have a
button to shut Ethan up well that's true
but it's the inverse of we have a button
to shut the host of the show power to
the people right
yeah that's true uh thank you for the
Dono J Christopher as well okay so I
love these details then he also was told
explicitly that if they were riffing
Crowder must always get the last word
who's on
this one's great
here
that's I I I don't know I've never heard
of that to be honest I mean I don't feel
like that's a thing but maybe what do I
know I've never been a co-host I've
heard in the radio a couple times yeah
but I have heard of it where it's just
the star needs to look like the star so
I guess you know it's it's his show fine
but I also feel like somebody who's So
Pro free speech and non-censorship he
was really about censorship okay
involved me
um but you know he was going through you
know surgery that was a big deal at the
time and stuff I was fairly forgiving of
it you know and then about a year in it
was February 2022 for the Super Bowl
right after 9 11. it was right after 9
11. uh like none of us could forget and
I was selling Flags I was making just a
mint off you're making a killing come on
that's money on the table I was making a
killing at Ground Zone guys yes dude
this is the thing I don't want to hear
about the stupid little [__] I want
to hear the T no small American flags
there's a lot of that cut to the chase
yeah that's why you had the light I was
I was trying to build a mosque Three
Doors Down from Ground Zero uh and
people were very obsessed and I didn't
understand why so these are my beliefs
and uh so I was I was uh plotting
um a big Patriot Day event and uh that
was a big day so
I forgot where we were talking about a
year after uh yeah he wanted me to film
a special okay
and um
okay stand-up comedy so I had decided I
was going to buy the equipment from the
special in Dallas
[Music]
that's so good I I can't take credit I'm
giving that to Ian oh yeah
okay I like the collaborative nature
back there yeah yeah good one we were
selling out this theater
and he decided he wanted to get back
into stand-up which he had done when he
was younger okay he had just been a host
since then
uh so he said hey if I can I jump on and
open it and I'll help promote it and you
can help me maybe write some of my my
stuff get me back into it idiot dummy
you want this guy to help you right
promote it and I said sure of course so
we ended up selling out two shows
obviously instead of just one because he
was helping promote it and he's a draw
so
we went there and Matt McCleary was the
opener he's been on the show as well if
people can look back yep
sorry autistic yes uh yeah the real deal
the real the room that's not a shooter
love that and candy
if he's really passing as a freak yeah
he does a great job born a lady but
totally
and uh yeah he he uh went up and got a
standing ovation after Stephen and
Stephen kind of saw we were friends and
after that uh I you know pulled Stephen
aside and Stephen couldn't do the Monday
show and I said could
Matt come in and and co-host with me he
said yeah
so now it's Super Bowl Sunday the whole
special world that one was so nice the
last one in the can you rewind the
the kinetic sand thing
that one was so nice with like the neon
blue and black
I can't watch I can't watch it
okay I'll I'll just blend him on it yeah
I'll just play it right
um I paid everybody to film it except
for uh one other person Tim who was
there to film Steven said and I was very
looking forward to the special coming
out and Monday had uh or Sunday had
rolled around then I get a call from the
show runner
wait this is the critical part okay no
no no no no cannot he finally he finally
got to the point right here I want to
hear this what did they tell you like
literally what they say uh via text it
was just
um Matt's not allowed uh Matt can uh
it's been like decided something like
that Matt I can find the text but the
word is allowed it's not like we don't
have time or we won't fit the schedule
the word
or something like that yeah yes yeah to
do the show on Monday is there any
explanation at all no
okay so I said that's odd I already
asked Stephen and he said it was okay
yeah and they said oh that's weird I
must have gotten mixed messages so I
just text Steven and said hey I just
talked to the showrunner
um I just want to make sure it's still
cool that Matt comes in and he texts me
something back along the lines of what's
done is done oh oh and I said what does
that mean it's your show wait but wait
maybe maybe he had a light and when the
light went on decision making there we
go see dude you're in something good
stay on stay focused my friend
the white pill
this is called apparently see you have
the yellow light he's got the red light
in his house there's it's it's lights
all the way up it's true
he maybe when I asked him he was seeing
a green light yes you idiot yeah I I
know
so business works it's this is why it is
the business of show and yeah you guys
are not in Showbiz
you're in no biz
got him
um
because you ain't got no job and I know
who you are but you're annoying
I am not paying attention to that how
are you gonna show things without lights
you're gonna show me okay guys so
apparently there's something here where
it says
can I just tell the story I can tell the
story better than Dave it's his story
I would like I think it's more effective
from him I don't know if it is I
genuinely don't know if it is something
about
he has Steven has to get the last word
uh I think you accidentally skipped past
that okay that was that whole thing that
you were watching was this next time
stamp uh
I didn't realize
click the one where it says he had to
get the last word okay maybe it's the
wrong time stamp then or something I
don't know that's I I don't know I've
never heard of that to be honest I mean
I don't let me go back let me go back it
was probably right before it was
important to oh yeah dude that one is so
nice what is that is it glowing wow yeah
I Can't Take My Eyes Off of that
stunning it was beautiful converted it's
inverted you think and the way it fell
too really nice golly that is something
man that's pretty I've seen this literal
compilation before because I watch Yo
that one's a fire yeah
I always felt that my job as a comedian
was to leave out the good one
that's I that's it was before this too
can we just move on from this point
nope I'm trying to ever we were just
through that other story about another
crazy thing that Crowder did and now
right before the point of the story
we've
gone down well
find the time stamp at least then while
I move on
okay
or somebody you know what I mean
moving on really
he explains Crowder screamed at him once
and said he owns him that was the part
that you just he never said he didn't
say that I know you were just getting
the point of the whole story I agree I
know I apologize it was the wrong thing
don't yell at me I'm not yelling but
let's don't make me hit the [__]
button
Dan can I just can I just can I just
tell the story
like I know the information and I can
spit it out in like two seconds and Dave
is going to take 15 minutes to get
through this what's done is done what's
done is done Dan right it's right after
this that he screams it what happened
I want to hear it okay
he went on tour Stephen Crowder hopped
on it he had two openers Stephen Crowder
and this other guy that's a friend of
his Steven isn't going to be there on
the Monday after the show so Dave asks
him hey
Stephen can my friend co-host with me
and he's like yeah no problem the next
day he gets a text from the showrunner
saying that guy's not allowed on the air
he texts Steven said hey what's up you
said it was cool Steven gets on the
phone with him starts screaming at him
that he's nothing without him and uh you
know that sounds good I want to see it
what does that mean it's your show which
isn't ironic that's what he said and my
phone rings and you know we're here
greatly into the conversation between us
but it was it he's like do you wanna do
you still want to be on with Crowder and
I said not at the moment
and he starts going off on me and now
there's a ton of people in my apartment
who can hear it like he's literally
raising his voice he's screaming at me
okay so literally raising his voice not
just being stern like he just said
screaming bro yeah dumb ass bro are you
screaming yeah okay so but he was
raising his voice they just said
screaming
how far out was he projecting do what
you say that actually seems like a line
of questioning I would pursue
what was the base decibels yes okay it's
uh started Stern but then it got into
telling me that he owns me and in those
words yes
I'm sorry yeah yeah yeah
it must have been on clearance I mean I
I was on sale baby neither of us can
even reach the time I own you that's
awesome what a [__] psycho
um Crowder also was supposed to tour
with that comedian but Crowder insisted
the other community couldn't do his
closing bit on stage because he was too
funny
the same guy they're talking about now
exactly just because I don't like being
talked to like that yeah at all
um but it was really I thought that was
your job Little Leprechaun [__] boy bro
I don't you sat there and peddled like
hateful violent freak [__] and like now
you're gonna claim and complain that
Daddy Steven yelled at you yeah actually
to be clear
um it becomes clear over the course of
this interview that uh he was a big uh
writer for the show so Dave believes all
the things that Crowder does good yeah
so he's just as big as just as big as
he's like yeah so anyway after the
segment where we called for the genocide
of trans people right he yelled at me
and it was really mean because that was
really mean the way you did that we're
not we're not sympathizing yeah right
when we got done reenacting uh the
murder of George Floyd he looked at me
weird and it made me feel kind of bad
comical in a lot of ways because it's
just I understand that there's going to
be a touch of narcissism to anybody
who's sort of in that field I get it not
me yeah yeah but at the same time it was
it was so over the top that I was trying
not to laugh
and then he said Matt couldn't do his
closing bid which was killer because it
was too dirty and I and you've seen wait
wait wait hold on hold on the he
couldn't do the closing bit on stage if
we were going to tour together in the
future Matt couldn't do his is his
closing bit on stage somehow that comes
up so you could tell there was this
projection of how he was angry of how
well that bit did wait yeah he had said
it got a standing oh because it was so
funny right God he's insecure
uh must be hard to maintain a relation
of marriage when you're that insecure
yeah that's true
[Music]
um
let's see there's so many good stuff in
here it's actually quite shocking since
we're talking about insecure this one's
probably good because this is where he
just straight up I was just saying he's
a well this one okay yeah I'll click
this one he thinks Crowder was bullied a
lot
and why he's now an insecure bullet yeah
the the and that's the part that
I don't think he ever grasped was I was
very and I'm still very forgiving of him
because whatever he has and whatever
he's going through I just think he was
bullied at some point in his life and
he's be he has become the bully and he
doesn't realize it and that's what sucks
is he's he's got a lot of yes men around
him and I really do love his staff and I
love him unlike you huh
he wasn't a yes man right camera not him
not him not the little leprechaun who
[__] did river dancing to transphobia
come on shut up dude
with them but I think that they are kind
of just a little bit intimidated at this
point to keep their own job I know I was
so I don't blame him [__] but it's just
he there's just something there that I
just don't grasp because dude he sounds
like a terrorist man on set
um
he also told uh uh the leprechaun he
wasn't allowed to promote his comedy
show on the show
and that's awesome
love that for him
then the money changed and all of a
sudden I noticed that I wasn't allowed
to promote my own shows on Crowder
unless it was behind the paywall or
right how are you told that you're not
allowed to promote your show like the
shows would start and two minutes before
show time somebody would walk out to me
and go hey you can't promote your show
today
Stephen would just his operations isn't
bigger than ours he was like hey go go
tell leopardy yeah be like you
whispering to me to tell Zach that he
can't promote the Roxy show can you
imagine like the culture of what is
there behind so uncomfortable you to
tell Zach not to promote Roxy live uh
14. I can't I can't promote Zach Lewis
live with the rocks in May 3rd don't I
said don't say that right the one want
to promote Zach Lewis life of the Rocks
no no no promoting Zach Lewis live at
the Roxy May 13. no never don't ever say
that again Zachary Lewis live at the
Roxy
but you hired a comedian he's a
professional comedian and then you tell
him like he's doing this for exposure
I mean the kind of exposure he's getting
is more like the Nuremberg uh trials
kind of exposure but I suppose you're
nonetheless
no it was just it was more to it's like
demeaning so you'd be like oh thanks
okay let's let me try let me play
Devil's Advocate was it the kind of
thing when you were on the show you
would just use any excuse to bring up
your show to promote it so they wanted
to kind of pull back on that no never
once he just wanted to promote his shows
that we were both on together or the
ones that he started doing in clubs
which I realized that my agent was
booking that even though I had asked my
agent if he started repping Stephen I
was never given a straight answer until
obviously I figured out that
that night in Dallas my agent had flown
there to sign Steven and wow now it was
his bigger client that's awesome
I love them
such a such a such good vibes like you
could tell back yeah for sure
the only great thing would be is if
leprechaun Dave [__] his wife
foreign
that's the real story
damn that'd be juicy I'm waiting for
candy he had a he had a family member
very sick which Crowder knew
and he was suddenly told he could he
couldn't go check on them
this [__] demonic dude I get back
from breaking at this time I I wouldn't
go into anything about Steven's family
and I wouldn't want him to do anything
about mine either obviously and but
somebody in my family was very very sick
and had been battling at something for a
while seriously
and he knew that and I came back and he
gave that an ugly talentless family
member yes and it was just probably a
lesbian it's me and I'll tell you uh no
matter how much work is done on this
face
this mug yeah God has cursed me uh
that's why they wanted to change mug
club uh it was just any association and
uh so we
talk about the allegations bro I'm
starting to think this shut up Dave
button was a good idea yeah
um yeah actually Crowder was pretty
based for that
but why hire someone that you hate that
you don't respect
damn so I get back and the first thing I
do is I get brought to lunch and I get
presented with this option with a new
contract Now Dave before you talk about
your contract and the importance of
money let's talk a little bit about
Patriot gold
that was so [__] sleep he's about to
sling gold coins I know it yeah yeah for
sure folks if you've been on the fence
about buying gold and silver have you
seen what's good why don't the gold I
never been approached by little young
people maybe we have and we said no
that's stupid
I don't think I don't remember ever
seeing one of those would you guys buy
gold coins from us I get along with the
theory is you bury them in your yard or
something
uh what's the theory with those they're
shiny doubloons
respect to the moon it's an investment
because the price of gold will
theoretically go I know but they're
sending you gold oh this is they're not
sending you gold I I don't know I've
never they probably are because yeah I
mean it's advertising what kind of
investment is that you just have a bar
of gold I mean it's shiny dude I don't
get that buy this commemorative Trump
coin only a few available you know
all right let's let's skip forward this
wonderful gold uh advert quickly sorry
about that
I'm good on gold coins for now
or just go to malasgull.com
Patriot Gold group is consumer affairs
Thompson malice like hate
malice gold malice means like hey that's
that dude's name oh well Fitz
a gold irate dealer six years in a row
so call 888-505 90 45 or just go to
maleschool.com they got a phone number
right never had an ad where they gave me
a phone number that's so weird oh [__] a
physical phone number that's not right
new contract says
that I
my I'm now my old contract is terminated
okay officially it's officially
terminated as of August 2022 and my new
choices I have to be there Monday
through Friday I I gotta probably look
at the stipulations if you want me to
pull it up real quick yeah pull it up
yeah I can send one to you it's uh
it was um how do you bring this hot of
tea and still be boring
all right Matt I hope his button was
like a pot of gold with a rainbow so
like the light shot out like a rainbow
there was a little pot of gold so that
told him to shut up and he was chasing
for his lucky charms yeah
that air
and I can just I can even just read it
it's just yeah read it again this was
sent to my age it's like this is just
simply the contract it was
uh William just need a yes I grant all
the revised items from Dave and this is
what Jeff showed me at lunch and it was
once I I get uh with our legal team on
the revised contract below it stays on
salary so no extra money
moves uh to Texas uh Moose's family to
Texas uh by the New Year first week so
you are I'm sorry part of your contract
a proposed contract was that your family
has to be moved across state lines
correct including your kid you have a
son how old's your son eight seven let
me guess Steven gave him a bunch a big
old budget to help him out with that
huge cost
I think he already mentioned uh no bump
in pay raise
actually but surely if you asking an
employee to move across state lines you
have to give them some uh
some financial support for having moved
okay so pull them out of school during
the school year and he's coming to Texas
okay yeah Dave is here every week unless
he notifies us well in advance for a
show just like a doctor's appointment
can't be gone any more than every third
weekend
no wait so let's break this down also
Steven has started touring as a comedian
yes Steven is no dummy Stephen is well
very well aware that you and every comic
weekends are when you tour hit the road
you make the money so he is very
um clearly taking that secondary or even
primary possibly at this point source of
income from you because you're just
going to be sitting in Dallas uh for no
reason because it's not like you're
doing shows on the weekends with Crowder
right and gone
every other third weekend means every
six weeks okay and then rides for show
everyone I'm sorry shut up dude
let him talk
I just want to break is this how people
feel when they watch me
down was it ever said to you or
intimated to you oh my God damn it is
affecting somehow your performance or
writing for them okay whatever whatever
Steven's a giant he's a just a mean guy
um
please don't make us sit through like
five I love these you added them this is
I didn't think you were gonna watch
every single one what did you think I do
look Dave wasn't allowed in rehearsal he
would just sit in a separate room
um talking about daily wire stuff he
felt degraded they made him dress like
an elf yeah I thought that that one's
pretty funny because well let's be
honest bro I mean what is your job there
I thought you were like the ceremonial
elf slash Leprechaun
what so what they made you dress like
how you feel inside what was the break
the break trans uh transa Kings actually
the uh he's trans else trans leprechaun
winter break
um right after he does his uh like Santa
thing okay
um where like we went out for a minute
and like I was dressed as an elf and I
felt a bit degraded and uh so I only
like I I think I
I'm sorry bro I don't care that's funny
you dressed your ass as an elf and you
felt the funniest thing Stephen Crabb
has ever done
oh
right we filmed a couple things like we
had some Visa cards and I was asking
people questions and then I just started
handing them to people that didn't speak
the language and then um because I
figured he'd never show that
um so I um
right before the break I was in his
office and it was me him and John that's
it I guess uh he felt degraded in the
elf costume we love that Crowder told
Dave he wished he made the amount of
money Dave did what does that mean
into his office and he said
how he wished that he made the amount of
money that I did last year and all this
other stuff said that or included for
that yes
what he was implying that you made more
money than him were significantly more
money than him way more money than him
yeah
that's weird and I well so this leads
into I guess where the divorce happened
yeah
so when crutter's second divorce right
second divorce in a year tough
so it was only when Dave the leprechaun
heard Crowder uh complaining about his
50 million dollar deal that he realized
how badly he was being ripped off
here it is
but then Jeremy came out and outed it
too Jeremy the head of this daily wire
right and I saw and I thought 50 million
dollars you know and I like looked at it
it turned down 50 million let's be clear
or up I think 50 million was the ceiling
but it wasn't starting at 50 but yeah he
he yes for 50 million dollars Ben
Shapiro can have my foot oh for 50
million I couldn't even believe it but
it's also going
it hit me too though because that means
oh what are we worth that I just sat in
an office yeah and was shamed
the timeline met up Marxist King
yeah he's
yeah he's coming
he's right up to a realization here this
dude is awesome he's he just realized
his work is being exploited by Stephen
and it's not fair he's weird
careful where you're going with that
line of thought there brother back in
August that he first got this 50 million
dollar offer through my agent that I
introduced him to oh right yeah was at
the same time that he knew what was
going on in my personal life that he
decided to slide me a contract that said
you have to do all this yeah when he was
being offered 50 million yeah people are
saying how much it costs to run the
studio and everything else it's like I
know how much it costs it's not that
much compared to 50 million my God
so the way that I lifted it I was like a
challenger yeah let's not know
but it's not 50 million yeah hell he's
making a ton of money which I'm not
saying he doesn't deserve but it's like
at the same time you knew that you were
making a profit and I was working very
hard to help you make that profit and
you were careful you're going with this
[__] you I'm gonna take everything from
home
careful wait a minute I thought we
believed in the free market down the
wrong path there buddy he deserves that
he works way harder than you he's the
boss
this man just realized that uh
the exploitation of workers cannot
continue
we we uh Revolution is required
and I just kind of was watching that
like is this for real yeah and then they
came back and said well we're going to
kind of negotiate where you know we come
back with something you come back with
something this isn't a contract this is
an offer sheet and I listen to both
sides and I thought well it seems that
Jeremy's being very upfront and
transparent here because he's pointing
out everything
So I listened to a bunch of you know
different Talking Heads but from what I
could gather
uh each side had their points but I felt
that it was more of a stop Big Calm
thing seemed a little much yeah and it
seemed like so he turned on crowder when
he was he's being such a big ass [__]
boy over the daily wire thing yeah he
was on the inside and even he was like
what is this Crowder complaining about
he says he thought it was on about
he says he thought it was [__] up but
play The Daily wire tapes and call it
slave wage when he uses labor from
slaves from other countries for his
merch careful bro
and watch where you're telling
um
but at the same time I'm like oh he's in
a business where maybe he needs to for
whatever protection I get it I didn't
get me too really easily you know how it
works yeah I get it yeah so it's like I
I really didn't think it was that big of
a deal I did think it was a big deal to
play it on the air yeah and to call it
slave wages when you buy clothing and
mugs from slave wage countries where
children make [__] and you're saying
you're a patriot like that bothers
he's like listen if anybody knows slave
wages it's us we employ child laborers
but he's right 50 million dollars is
certainly not slave wage that's actually
quite embarrassing to even say and he
says finally the last straw was Crowder
playing the tapes he thinks Crowder was
the wrong and he and the wrong and he
quit right after I want leprechaun Dave
to get his own show on daily wire that
would be a nice knife in the back huh
yeah I don't know if that offers on the
table for him thing runs on hypocrisy
and drama that's a lubricant of our
society but it was all this infighting
you know going at each other uh saying
of who was right and who was wrong and I
thought it was very clear who was right
and who was wrong
it was playing a private conversation it
shouldn't have been done that's my
honest opinion
um so I was gonna go back onto the show
um I uh I was getting paid I sent in a
few things but
I did have jury duty on a day and and
it goes on and on about this jury duty
and
all right yeah bro is he on the next
season of jury duty yeah maybe is he
season two
so there it is uh it's all falling down
for Crowder and I love it yeah but
you're saying his fans are not bothered
by any of this
um well a small sample size of people on
like his subreddit and stuff um I mean
when you make the daily wire guys look
like the good guys you are really a
demon
yeah and uh well he is
I assume they were homies or something
you know but apparently he just hated
him the whole time
there it is guys
so dick Crowder's wife left Tim Lowell
there it is that's the show
dad and Dave
our two boys
oh I got pictures of the boys at a
bookstore
oh brucey's walking and picking out
books it's crazy so cute oh my God so
cute in a book
yes in a book
so uh yeah One Last Detail because I saw
a lot of people asking about in the chat
because your little box was covering it
on the bottom right but Dave was wearing
an idol shirt in that interview uh which
is very strange Idols is like a punk
band that is very explicitly left wing
um I don't know how he could be a fan of
theirs this is very strange is Dave
perhaps just
in it for the money being a hateful
bigot for money I mean I don't know or I
mean
there's a lot of conservatives that like
Rage Against the Machine too and they
are like explicitly Marxist so I I don't
know should we get Dave to call in I
could conduct a better interview than
that goofball and he's got tea
yeah I don't know if he would agree to
that Dave call in
if you all got Dave send him I want to
talk to Dave the leprechaun
in fact you don't I won't make you dress
up like an elf I'll dress up like a
leprechaun for you oh
I'll humiliate myself for you that's
pretty big of you Little River dance to
the beat of transphobia
and we promise not to have Sam Cedar on
the call if you're afraid of him too he
will not be on that yeah
no no no I would never do that not to
Dave yeah Dave's family
um but this is all pretty good I mean
it's all pretty quite delicious so the
the irony the downfall here is Dave
tweeting out a picture Merry Christmas
from all of us elves Santa does sex
stuff to us he's a monster
200 likes cool Russian it Dave good
stuff Dave come on the show please
message him
from the podcast we we love Dave we
support Dave
uh I guess but anyways tomorrow morning
we'll be back with leftovers where we
will probably continue to tap dance on
uh the grave of Stephen Crowder's
marriage there's a lot more to talk
about than that though it's been a big
week
with the Tucker getting uh right fired
and all that yeah we'll probably we'll
we'll probably I want to kind of stick
to the news stories tomorrow as much as
we can Tucker
well yeah sorry we didn't get to do the
prostate exam today we'll work on that
hopefully have that for you guys soon
[Music]
and um maybe Dave will come for a
prostate exam
maybe maybe we can we'll let him know
it's free
it's free it's free and he's probably I
mean he looks older than me I'm assuming
he's a bit older
yeah he's definitely within the range
that it's appropriate to get one so
maybe pitch that to him Olivia if you're
writing
one more time
I would like him to invite him to
participate in the prostate exam
I'll include that
yeah you want a finger in the butt
that's what I'll say would you like to
be digitally penetrated on this just a
little PS at the end P.S like how do you
feel about this 39 yeah I'm seeing oh
he's 39 yeah so it's it's time
it's time he's fine man it's time Dave
come to the come here we care about not
only you but your health ah he's from
Detroit
is that a rough one for you yeah that's
rough sorry about that sorry about that
and you can say come as much as you want
on Earth yeah dude come on over and come
come come
all right guys we'll see you tomorrow
morning with leftovers thanks everyone
for being here
um love you all so much thank you to our
gracious members you guys uh
make it all happen for us here
especially when we don't have sponsors
like today
so thank you guys and we'll see you for
leftovers tomorrow
thank you everybody have a good night